THE ASSEMBLY
HIGHER END COMMITTEE IS BECAUSE
INTO- WITH THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. SO WELCOME ALL TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION BILL HEARING. WHETHER
YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE LINES
I'M GLAD YOU HAVE JOINED US.
PLEASE NOTE THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
KEVIN KILEY WILL BE ABSENT FROM
TODAY'S HEARING. I WILL NOW GO
OVER SOME KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S HEARING.
DUE TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC
WE'RE STILL PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT TO OBSERVE
AND PARTICIPATE DURING THIS
HEARING. IF YOU'RE HERE IN
PERSON PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE
MASTER NO LONGER REQUIRED THEY
ARE RECOMMENDED REGARDLESS OF
YOUR VACCINE STATUS. LIKE TO
WEAR A MASK AND DO NOT HAVE ONE
PLEASE NOTE THAT MASTER
AVAILABLE FREE OF CHARGE AT THAT
SECURITY CHECKPOINTS AT THE
ENTRANCE OF THE CAPITOL BUILDING
. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. IN PERSON AND VIA THE
PHONE LINES. FOR IN PERSON IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IS IN
THE ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING WHEN
SHE FINISHED TESTIFYING OR YOU
CAN RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE
BE SURE TO RESERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE AND UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE
ELEVATOR. TO THE INDICATED
NUMBER ON THE SIGNS POSTED BY
THE ELEVATOR DOORS. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING THE AT&T MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND
EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS. ON THE
BILL. THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY SO AGAIN I ASK THAT ALL
INVOLVED TO REMAIN PATIENT. THE
PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING. IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE
NUMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION OMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR MONITOR
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO BUT AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING. IS BEGINNING THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN QUEUE. BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST. ON YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE SURE TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE. AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE
SIX ZERO AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WILL DO THEIR BEST TO RESIST
ASSIST YOU. PLEASE NOTE THAT WE
ARE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL OR THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE GUIDELINES FOR
BILLS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
SPEAK FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH. STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
AND ENTITIES THAT THAT ARE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT NOR IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES WHEN I CALL FOR
TWEETERS. THE MEASURE HAS MORE
THAN TWO ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER
CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH. THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE AND METHODS CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL OR ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMENT. AND
ASKED DID YOU RAISE YOUR HAND TO
ACTIVATE YOUR VOLUME BUTTON ON
THE DIESS MICROPHONES. FOR
AUTHORS OF BILLS EACH MEMBER
PRESENTING TODAY IT WILL PROVIDE
AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENTS. ADDITIONALLY AS I
PREVIOUSLY STATED- LEAD WITNESS
WHO EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE HAVE
SIXTEEN MEASURES ON THE AGENDA
TODAY WITH THREE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MEASURES WILL BE TAKEN
UP AND FILE ORDER. AND I WILL
PRESENT MY BILLS LAST MEASURES
ON CONSENT R. AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SIX. FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY TWO FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AND AJ R. TWENTY SIX FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN. SO DO DO IS A
SCHEDULING CONFLICT WE'RE GONNA
TAKE UP FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FIRST. AT THIS
TIME I WILL ASK VICE CHAIR DR
CHOI TO BEGIN HIS TESTIMONY AND
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FILE
ITEM CHAT. DR CHOI. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEDINA AND A DOCTOR MEMBER
DR WEBBER- IMPRESSION- I IN
THIS- HEARING. OF THE COMMITTEE
SEP COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION I'M SO PLEASED TO
PRESENT THE ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IT IS A
VERY SIMPLE BILL- TO INDICATE-
MENTAL HEALTH HOTLINE PHONE
NUMBERS SO ON THE- OF COLLEGES
CHILDREN- ID'S AB OUT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TOOL DIRECTS A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND-
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IS
SET AND THE REQUESTS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
INCLUDE IT HERE MENTAL HEALTH
HOTLINE NUMBER ON EITHER SIDE OF
THESE CHILDREN IDENTIFICATION
CARDS. THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
UNIVERSITIES SO WHO DO NOT HAVE
THEM- MENTAL HEALTH HOTLINE TO
INCLUDE THE EITHER THE- KALLONI
OR A CITY MENTAL HEALTH THE
HOTLINE AND ENCOURAGE USE OF
THOSE- CAMPUSES UP TO IS THE
ABOLITION OF THE- OWN HOTLINE
FOR THE STUDENTS TO. ACCESS A.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE FOR TOO SUFFER FROM-
A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND THE
MAY NOT SEEK OUT HELP WHEN
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE. WHEN WE
ALREADY KNOW ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS
WAS SO FURTHER HEIGHTENED BY THE
EPIDEMIC THESE ARE PASSED TO TWO
YEARS SO WHEN IN PERSON HELP WAS
NOT THE PROVIDED. THE INCLUSION
OF THE ACTUAL CAMP. MENTAL
HEALTH THE HOTLINE WHEN THE
STUDENT HAD THEM. CARDS WILL
ENSURE THAT THE COLLEGES TO. HEY
A TO MENTAL HEALTH THE- SUCH UP
. HI OF THE ON SO IN A VERY
CONVENIENT TO EACH YEAR. L. O.
PORTING CAL SAID THE CASE TO A
SUB STUDENTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
I REALLY APPRECIATE BY PASSING
HIS SAW- IMPORTANT- IN AB TWENTY
pHAVE A A. B. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO- IS A SPONSOR KIMBERLY- WITH
. A GENERATION OF. BEHIND
POLYGYNY. ALL TO A TEST. IN
SUPPORT AND THE NORTH IN. WITH
ME TODAY IS- TOSSED ME IN THE-
BROSSART NOW WITH HIS CHILDREN
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THANK YOU DR CHOI. I
WILL GO TO THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR FOR THE FIRST WITNESS-
ON THE LINE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR. A WITNESS THANK YOU.
THAT LINE IS OPEN MISTER. I CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. STOP IT MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
WILL I'M A JUNIOR AT UC BERKELEY
I THOUGHT WAS A DOCTOR JACK
LEACH'S GENERATION UP OR
JAPANESE EDUCATIONAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WILL BE SENT
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE AND THE SPENDING
NATIONAL. HOW PROVIDING BOB
GENERAL ADVOCATE WHOSE NUMBER
BILL. TWO ONE TWO TWO FIVE OPEN
I THINK IN THE COMMUNITY AMONG
HOLDEN IT AGE AB TWENTY TWENTY.
WASHINGTON INCLUSION OF. AND
LOCAL MENTAL HOW HI JUSTIN. MY
EXPERIENCE I AM A CALLING MY
UNIVERSE. BUT TO HELP BETTER
ENJOY NINETEEN. AFTER YOU THE
MATH IN MY MIND BREAKDOWN ON THE
DRIVE TO SCHOOL. BOTH MILE MY
SHOULD WAS PUT- I'M OKAY. I
FINALLY MY THE COURAGE THE HELP
MIGHT AT MY UNIVERSITY CASH NOW
MATTHEW MY DAD. HELPLESSNESS
WHAT I NOT EVEN WITH A CALL
MILLION IS NOT TO HELP. ALL THE
FEARS OF WAR IF I COULD AT LEAST
IT BECAME TOO WE THE CHIU TO GO
TO ASK WITH NOT A WHOLE USERS
IS. A MIKE DOOR IS NOT YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY UP TO SEVENTY FIVE
OF STRUCK STUDENTS HELLO TO HELP
WHICH MAY AB ONE TO TWO SO CLOSE
TO WIN AWARENESS. YOU'RE GOING
TO THIRTY ALSO OUT THERE WITH
YOU SEE WHAT UNIVERSE HOW
INTRIGUED. SUCH HEALTH STRUGGLES
NOT BE TOO. NOW BACK AT
ISOLATION FINANCIAL BURDEN AND
BRING PROBABLY ALONG RIGHT. INTO
2080% CULTURE ABOUT THE DEMAND
HEALTH WITH NEGATIVELY BY. AND I
RELATE MANY TIMES OF A CO. ABOUT
TWO CLASS YEAH. AND EIGHT
DESCRIBED BY IN TOMORROW. AND
THANKFULLY OQOQO PAU TO HELP
REDUCE IMPROVE BECAUSE NEARLY
EVERYTHING TO BE A TO BE STATE
DURING THE- WHICH ME COUNTLESS
OTHERS TO THEM UNDER JENNY.
MUSTARD HEARING TO ASK. IN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ALL EXTRA
HOT WHEN OUT OF THINK WE CAN. WE
ARE JOHN UP. YOU TO SUPPORT AB
ONE TO TWO TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS GROW INTO MEANING.
THOUGH GIVEN A MOST BASIC NEED
FROM FOOD TO OVER WELL BEING.
THAT WE CAN PUT OUR ACADEMIC
ABOUT. AND MOST PEOPLE. A
CRUCIAL HOW. THANK YOU SO. THANK
YOU.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS JUST
THE START OF ALLOWING STUDENTS
TO REACH OUT WHEN THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH A MENTAL CRISIS. OUR
MENTAL HEALTH IS A HUGE FACTOR
IN OUR OVERALL BODILY FUNCTIONS
IF WE AREN'T FINDING WAYS TO
COPE WITH THEM WE AREN'T
BENEFITING OUR STUDENTS. SOCIETY
HAS ONLY BEGUN TO REALIZE THE
SERIOUSNESS OF A STUDENT'S
MENTAL HEALTH. AND HOW IT
IMPACTS THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION.
STUDENTS OFTEN FEEL LIKE A
NUISANCE WHEN TALKING TO A
FRIEND ABOUT THE STRUGGLES THEY
ARE FACING HOWEVER. ON THE THESE
HOTLINES IS COMPLETELY ANONYMOUS
WHICH ALLOWS COMFORTABLE TALKING
SPACES FOR THE STUDENTS. WE ARE
OBLIGATED TO IMPROVE OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESS AND THAT
INCLUDES MAKING THEM AWARE OF
WHAT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
JUST A CALL AWAY. STUDENT ID%
CARDS ARE USED EVERYWHERE ON
CAMPUS THING AS IT ALLOWS US TO
ACCESS OUR CAMPUS RESOURCES. WE
MUST ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESSIBLE RESOURCES WHEN
FINDING BALANCE TO ADDRESS THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUTTINGMENTAL
HEALTH HOTLINES ON THE BACK OF
STUDENT ID CARDS INTERESTED IN
TECH SUPPORT TO SUCCEED IN THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION. THEREFORE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
VOTE THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE MUCH IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND IF YOU'VE
PLACED YOURSELF IN QUEUE TO
SPEAK ON ANOTHER BILL ME REPEAT
THE COMMAND TO REMOVE YOURSELF
UNTIL THAT TIME. WHO. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL LINES IN Q. MISTER CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THE FIRST
COMMENT YES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IF THEY WOULD STATE THEIR NAME
AND- THE POSITION. NINE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE ON THE LINE TWENTY FOUR.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
TWO. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
YES I SUPPORT THIS BILL MY NAME
IS JOHN MARTIN WHICH AFTER
COLLEGE THANK YOU- NEXTEL NINE
ELEVEN. HI THIS IS MAGGIE MERIT
REPRESENTING THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
FOUR SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IN THE
ROOM. SEEING NONE WE GO EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. NO MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
ANY TWEETERS IN THE ROOM. ANY
TWEETERS- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR.
ON THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS POSITION A TWEENER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THANK YOU KNOW LINES IN
WHAT WE DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE TEN
LINE TEN YOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON PATRICIA ROCKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE DIDN'T TAKE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL WE
WERE NEUTRAL THOUGHT NO HE SAID
E JUST WANTED TO BE SURE THAT
THE INFORMATION PREPARED ON THE
CARDS. INCLUDE THAT THEIR
ASSURANCES THAT COULD BE
INFORMATION POSTED ON THE CARD
WOULD INCLUDE OUR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WILL CLEARLY THAT IS BY THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
AND MEET THE TYPICAL RIGHT HERE
YEAH FOR PROVIDING THE SERVICES
INCLUDING ANONYMITY FOR THE
STUDENTS. AS WELL AS THE
QUALIFICATION GROUP BOTH THE
STATE BANK OF THE STAFF THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED OF COURSE THAT
WOULD BE THE ONLY CONCERN THAT
WE HAD ABOUT STILL- AND WE DO
BELIEVE THIS. IS A GOOD IDEA.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER TWEENER-
MISTER MODERATE. YES WE DO WE
HAVE LINE. FORTY WHO WHO. JEFF
JOHNSON AT JOHNSON WHICH IS NOT
. THANK YOU OKAY THE PLAN HERE
TO WALK LICENSE SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN FIFTY TWO AND A EIGHT
EIGHT IF SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WINNERS ONLINE. NO
OTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO THEN TO THE COMMITTEE.
TO THE MEMBERS COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DR WEBER.
THANK YOU DR CHOI FOR- BRINGING
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT ACTUALLY
PRETTY COMMONSENSE BELL- JUST UP
BASED ON THE TWEENER COMMON I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I
AM CLEAR THE CARD WOULD JUST
HAVE THE PHONE NUMBER OF EITHER
AT THE COUNTY THE CITY OR THE IF
THE CAMPUS HAS A MENTAL HEALTH
LINE. THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE ON
THE CARD CORRECT YES NOT A LIST
OF RESOURCES JUST- NUMBER FOR
PEOPLE TO CALL RIGHT- AND SO I
THINK THAT'S GOOD THAT'S THAT'S
GREAT I WOULD- ALSO- RECOMMEND
THAT- YOU ALL THINK ABOUT IF YOU
HAVE AN ARTY THOUGHT ABOUT YOU
KNOW THERE IS A PUSH TO HAVE A
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE- AND IF THAT GOES
THROUGH I WOULD RECOMMEND YOU
ALL CONSIDER PUTTING THAT ON THE
CARD AS WELL- BUT- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THAT
PHONE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER. OR
COMMENTS. BUT SEEN NONE OF
DOCTOR CHOI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I THANK YOU THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE RAW IDEA TO HELP OF
MENTAL ISSUES- THAT THE HAS A
REASON NOT DURING THIS-
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND SPREADING UNFORTUNATELY
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE SO WHAT THIS
IS A ONE WAY OUT FOR EASY-
PROVISION OF- ACCESS- FOR THEM
TO. REACH OUT WHEN THEY ARE IN
NEED I APPRECIATE THE YOUR- I
VOTE TO HONE THIS IMPORTANT B.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DR CHOI AND-
OF. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRING IN
THE BILL FORWARD AND THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THE- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS REFLECTED ON PAGE
FIVE THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
WILL ASK YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
SEGMENTS- DRESSING THE NUMBER OF
TIMES THE REPORT IS RELEASED
WITH WITH WITH- NOT HAVING WE
STILL SHORT OF A QUORUM WE'LL
WAIT TILL WE GET A QUORUM TO-
TAKE A VOTE THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU DR CHOI. THANK YOU. SO
MOVING BACK IN BILL FILE ORDER
FILE ORDER NUMBER ONE. OF MISTER
ROBERTS. WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
YOU MAY PROCEED. WELCOME. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB BILL- SIXTEEN OH
SIX- THIS BILL MAKES THREE
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE COLLEGE
FEE WAIVER FOR THE VETERANS
DEPENDENTS PROGRAM THE FIRST
CHANGE THE PROGRAM THE LOWER THE
DISABILITY RATING REQUIRED FOR
THE SPOUSE OF A COMBAT DISABLED
VETERAN TO QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM FROM A 100% TO SEVENTY
PERCENT. UNDER THE PROGRAM AS IT
STANDS THE DEPENDENT CHILDREN OF
A VETERAN DISABLED AT ANY RATING
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE WAIVER BUT
SPOUSES HAVE TO MEET THIS
EXCEEDINGLY HIGH STANDARD. AS WE
KNOW NOT ALL FAMILIES LOOK THE
SAME AND NOT ALL COUPLES HAVE
CHILDREN. THIS EXCLUSION IS
ARGUABLY DISCRIMINATORY AND
EXCLUDES MANY DESERVING PEOPLE
FROM WHOSE VETERANS SPOUSES ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY DISABLED. THE
SECOND CHANGE WOULD ELIMINATE
THE PROHIBITION AGAINST
CONCURRENT RECEIPT OF FEDERAL
EDUCATION BENEFITS FOR DEPENDENT
SPOUSES. IT MAKES LITTLE SENSE
TO EXCLUDE PEOPLE FROM THIS
BENEFIT WHEN WE HAVE ALREADY
DEEMED THEM TO SERVING. SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE RECEIVING A
NOMINAL STIPEND OR OTHER SUPPORT
AIMED AT HELPING THEM. COMPLETE
THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION. THE
THIRD CHANGE WHAT A MAN THE
INCOME THRESHOLD FOR THE MEANS
TESTED DEPENDENT CHILD WAIVER
FROM THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
TO AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST ACCEPT
EXPENSIVE STATE IN THE NATION
AND THE FELLOW FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL IS SIMPLY TOO LOW A
THRESHOLD TO USED TO EXCLUDE
PEOPLE FROM SUPPORT. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CARLA SAY HOUSE WHOSE SPOUSE IS
A 100% DISABLED. MISTER CHAIR OF
BY WITNESS CAN BEFORE YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
CARLESS SAY HAAS FROM MERCED I
AM A MILITARY SPOUSE MY HUSBAND
SERVED TWENTY YEARS IN THE ARMY
AS A MEDIC HE IS A COMBAT
VETERAN WHO IS 1100% VA SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABLED. I AM ALSO A
PHD STUDENT AT UC MERCED I AM
HERE AS AN INDIVIDUAL IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTY NO SIX WHICH AMENDS
THE CALVET FEE WAIVER THAT CAN
BE USED AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CSU OR UC. CURRENTLY UNDER PLAN
A SPOUSES CAN ONLY BENEFIT FROM
THE FEE WAIVER IF THE VETERAN IS
1100% VA SERVICE CONNECTED
DISABLED AND SERVE DURING A
PERIOD OF WAR PLAN B. EXCLUDE
SPOUSES AND SUPPORTS CHILDREN'S
OF VETERANS WHO HAVE A 0% VA
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITY
RATING OR HIGHER AND DOES NOT
REQUIRE WARTIME SERVICE. THIS
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST MILITARY
SPOUSES SPOUSES OFTEN PUT THEIR
EDUCATION AND CAREERS ON HOLD
WHILE THE SERVICE MEMBERS SERVED
ON ACTIVE DUTY AB SIXTEEN OH SIX
WILL GIVE SPOUSES THE CHANCE TO
FURTHER THEIR EDUCATION IT ALSO
PROVIDES A SOLUTION FOR SPOUSES
RECEIVE CHAPTER THIRTY FIVE
BENEFITS DUE TO THEIR VETERAN
SPOUSE BEING 1100% VA SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABLED. I PERSONALLY
RECEIVED CHAPTER THIRTY FIVE
BENEFITS TO THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION THAT AMOUNTS TO
ROUGHLY TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR WHICH IS THE MAX ALLOWED
MEANT THIS BENEFIT IS FOR THIRTY
SIX MONTHS CURRENTLY UNDER PLAN
A OF THE CALVET FEE WAIVERS
SPOUSES RECEIVE CHAPTER THIRTY
FIVE BENEFITS FROM THE VA CANNOT
ALSO USE THE CALVET FEE WAIVER.
UNDER PLAN B. CHILDREN OF
VETERANS ARE ALLOWED TO USE
CHAPTER THIRTY FIVE BENEFITS AND
THE CALVET FEE WAIVER AT THE
SAME TIME THE AMENDMENT I WOULD
SUGGEST BE ADDED TO AB SIX YOU
KNOW SIX IS THE ABILITY TO USE
THE CALVET FEE WAIVER AT ANY CSU
OR UC EXTENSION PROGRAM
CURRENTLY THIS IS NOT AN OPTION.
A PLAN COMPLETION OF THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE COMMITMENT OF
MONTHS NOT YEARS VETERAN
DEPENDENTS CAN OBTAIN JOBS THAT
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE LIVING
WAGE WE MUST CREATE AN PASSED
POLICIES WHICH DECREASE BARRIERS
AND INCREASE SUPPORT FOR POST
NINE ELEVEN. I FAMILIES. AB SIX-
SIX WILL BE A BENEFIT TO ALL
CALIFORNIA VETERAN FAMILIES ONCE
PASSED. PLEASE VOTE YES AN
ADVANCE AB SIXTEEN OH SIX THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
MISTER ROBERTS DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES NOT AT THIS TIME
MISTER- ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. THE C. NINE
EIGHTEEN TEAM UP MODERATOR ARE
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINE. THANK YOU TO STATE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO PLEASE. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TEN YEAR OPEN. WILL
MOVE THE LINE. FORTY FOUR ZERO.
HI MY NAME IS BRENDA WELL BEING
AND I TEACH ENGLISH AT CYPRESS
COLLEGE WHEN I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
JOURNAL FOR THE LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SCENE NINE EIGHTEEN TO YOUR
MODERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN USING
YOUR PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN Q. ARE THERE ANY
TWEETERS IN THE HEARING ROOM.
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE LINES. TO
EXPRESS BETWEEN- POSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND ZERO PLEASE. WHO
EMBERTON WE HAVE LINE TEN LINE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
PATRICIA RECORD CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OTHER
FUTURE APOLOGIZE I HAD A
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY AND COULD
NOT EXPRESS THE ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL EARLIER.
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
TWEETERS IN ON THE LINE. NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME WE'LL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. FROM
THE COMMITTEE. DR TRYING. THANK
YOU CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS-
I THINK THIS IS A VERY-
SENSITIVE- AND THE QUINCY
CONSIDERED BE ALL THAT YOU ARE
PRESENTING- RB IN SUPPORT OF
THAT UP BUT I HAVE A QUESTION I
WONDER IF- THIS BILL IS A
TARGETED- HELPING SPOUSES OR
DISABLED ARE VETERANS- THEY
SHOULD BE ALSO FULLY QUALIFIED
THE FULL OR THE ALEXA- CAL GRAND
MOFF APPS ARE. FEDERAL AND A
STATE- RESOURCES UP MARK FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING PLENTY OF THE NOT
COVERED ENOUGH FOR- SO THAT THE
YOU ARE A INTRODUCED THIS B. R.
TO SPECIFICALLY. WAIVE THAT
TUITION. HAVE YOU LOOKED INTO
THAT THE RE THAT THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN SUFFICIENT. THE
NECESSITATE THIS BEEN DID THIS
BILL. THIS BILL IS WHAT IS MEANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- THOSE
DESERVING OF THE DIFFERENT
RESOURCES ARE THERE THAT ARE
QUALIFIED FOR OTHERS THE
SPECIFICALLY THE- DEPENDENT
CHILDREN OF- SOMEONE THAT'S
DISABLED BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEIR SPOUSES ARE INCLUDED
ALSO FOUGHT WITHIN THAT TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE GETTING THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO FURTHER
THEIR EDUCATION IT ALSO LOOKS
AT- LOW RISK THAT AREA FROM A
100% TO SEVENTY PERCENT.
DISABLED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE BEING ABLE TO GET THE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES THAT WERE
PROMISED- FOR THE SERVICE- THAT
NOW HAS A DISABLED VETERAN. WHO
SERVED OUR COUNTRY. OKAY SO THIS
BILL- WILL ONLY WAIVE THE
TUITION AT THIS TIME. IT'S
GEARED TOWARDS LEAD AND WE'RE
EVEN EVEN EVEN IF WHEN THEY GET
THIS SET TUITION WAIVER WHEN
THEY PSTN ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
THE EXISTING GRAND SELF FROM THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL. IF I
WITNESSES WANT TO BECAUSE OUT
WHAT I WAS THE STAND IS THAT
THEY HAVE A CERTAIN LIMITATIONS
OF WHEN THEY RECEIVE THE
SCHOLARSHIPS OR GRANTS SO. THEY
HAVE A SUDDEN CAPITAL. AND THAT
THEY CANNOT GET THAT ANY FURTHER
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DISPUTE
OR DISADVANTAGE- IT GIVE A MORE
DISADVANTAGES THAN NOT HELPING
THEM. I BELIEVE IT WOULD NOT BE
A DISADVANTAGE IT WITH EXCEL THE
BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO THE
INDIVIDUAL TO PURSUE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT. I KNOW
THIS IS A TARGETED FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE SO WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY ARE IN THE LOW INCOME
CATEGORY THEY ALREADY HAVE. A
PLAN ANY OTHER SOURCES OF
CURRENTLY EXISTING WITH THE-
THIS IS A TUITION WAIVER FOR
SPOUSES AND DISABLED THE-
VETERANS CELL WHERE THE THAT
WOULD. ARE ACTUALLY NOT- HARMS
SOME HOME IN APPLYING FORCE. FOR
THOSE- ALTHOUGH- SCHOLARSHIP
WALK GRANT COUPLE JUNE EIGHTIES.
SO THIS BILL IS GEARED TOWARDS
THE MILITARY- PERSPECTIVE OF I
WAS ABLE TO VETERAN THAT'S THERE
AS FAR AS THE INCOME THERE'S
ALSO A COMPONENT IN THE BILL
THAT DEALS WITH THE FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL- ASPECT OF IT TO THE
LOCAL MEDIAN RANGE AS FAR AS
WHERE THEY THEY LAND ON THE
ECONOMIC. IMPACT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING THE
RESOURCES THAT UP TO THIS POINT
HAVE BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR THOSE
RESOURCES MOVING FORWARD. YEAH I
WOULD RECOMMEND THE FOR YOU TO
LOOK INTO THAT THE WITH THIS BE
A LOT WOULD BE ACTUALLY- IN NOT
NOT THE HARMING THEIR OR THE- IT
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES SO FROM THIS
BILL. WE ACTUALLY HAVE A AN
EXAMPLE FROM MY WITNESS THAT
ACTUALLY HAS BEEN IN THAT
SITUATION. YES THANK YOU- DOCTOR
CHOICE SO I AM CURRENTLY A FULL
TIME PHD STUDENT AT UC MERCED MY
HUSBAND AS I MENTION IS 1100%
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABLED SO I
QUALIFY TO USE THE CALVET FEE
WAIVER. HOWEVER AS THE SPOUSE OF
A SERVICE MEMBER WHO IS A 100%
VA SERVICE CONNECTED DISABLED I
ALSO AM ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
CHAPTER THIRTY FIVE BENEFITS
THROUGH THE VA ADMINISTRATION.
WITH THE CALVET FEE WAIVER I
CANNOT USE BOTH BENEFITS AT THE
SAME TIME SO I RECEIVED THE MAX
AMOUNT FROM THE VA WHICH IS TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR. AND
BECAUSE I TO RECEIVE THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR FROM
THE VA I CANNOT USE THE CALVET
FEE WAIVER SO THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR SPOUSES TO
USE BOTH I DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
CAL GRANT OR PELL GRANT BECAUSE
I AM IN AND- DOING THAT A
GRADUATE DEGREE NOT AN
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE. AND SO FOR
SPOUSES THIS HINDERS US AND
DOESN'T ALLOW US TO FURTHER
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN ONE OR THE OTHER
BENEFITS I'M ESSENTIALLY BEING-
PUT IN A POSITION WHERE I HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO HELP MY-
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. OR A TUITION
FEE WAIVER THAT WOULD HELP ME
EXCEL MY EDUCATION. GLAD TO HEAR
AS LONG AS THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
WILL NOT DISQUALIFY YOU FROM
WHAT THE ELIGIBLE RESOURCES. NO
CURRENTLY IT'S ACTUALLY
DISQUALIFIES ME FROM ACCEPTING
OTHER- RESOURCES SO THIS WOULD
HELP ME SO THAT I COULD USE MORE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS IS VIOLENCE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD YOU
KNOW I'M SUPPORTING OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME
ARE- MILITARY ARE VETERANS THEIR
SPOUSES AND CHILDREN- IS
SOMETHING THAT WE OWE TO THESE
FAMILIES TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY-
I DO HAVE A QUESTION THOUGH KIND
OF ABOUT- CLARIFICATION ON IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE A- I COUNTY APPROACH
INTO THAT TOO- DEFINING THE
MEDIAN INCOME SO MIKE MY
QUESTION IS DOES THE MEDIAN
INCOME. INCOME OF THE APPLICANT
APPLY TO WHERE THE APPLICANT IS
FROM OR WHERE THEY WILL BE GOING
TO SCHOOL AND THE REASON WHY I
ASK IS BECAUSE IF YOU'RE LIVING
YOU KNOW IN BAKERSFIELD THE COST
OF LIVING- AND THE COST TO GO TO
A COLLEGE IN BAKERSFIELD IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN IF YOU'RE GOING
TO SAN FRANCISCO STATE I'M SO
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE PAIRED IT WILL WORK AND
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE'RE
GONNA DEFINE. WHO WOULD QUALIFY
IN TERMS OF INCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
THAT CLARIFYING POINT AND WE
WILL LOOK INTO AND YOU BRING UP
A GOOD POINT AS FAR AS WHERE-
THE RESIDENT. IT IS AS AR AS
THE MEDIAN INCOME USE THEIR- AND
THE ACTUAL- IT HIGHER
INSTITUTION THAT THEY'RE GONNA
BE APPLYING FOR RATHER IT'S
RESIDENTS OR OR- OUT OF
RESIDENTS- TYPE COME. COMPLIANCE
SO WE'LL LOOK INTO THAT BUT THIS
IS GEARED TOWARDS- MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO HONOR- THE FAMILIES
AND ESPECIALLY IN THIS CASE
DISABLED VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THE AND THEIR AND
THEIR CHILDREN AND THEIR SPOUSES
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE- MISTER ROBERTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
INSIGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND
DIALOGUE- I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. I THANK YOU TO MISTER
ROBERTS FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I HAVE BY MYSELF IS
SPOKEN WITH MANY MILITARY
FAMILIES AND I'VE HEARD THE
COMMON REFRAIN THAT THE
SACRIFICE OF MILITARY SERVICE IS
ONE THAT SHOULD BE SHARED BY
EVERYONE. SERVICEMEMBER THEIR
SPOUSE THEIR CHILDREN SO THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION WILL GRANT
ACCESS TO CRITICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AND I'M VERY PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY- WE
STILL LACK OF FORM. A QUORUM SO
WE WILL TAKE A VOTE WHEN A
QUORUM IS PRESENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS- WITH WITH
APOLOGIES TO THE AUTHOR I'M
GONNA JUMP IN HERE I HAVE A
WITNESS THAT- NEEDS TO CATCH A
FLIGHT SO I'M GOING TO PRESENT
MY BILL AT THIS TIME AND THEN
WE'LL GO BACK. TO BILL PORTER.
WITHOUT A DOUBT GIVE THE- GAVEL
GAVEL TO. PROVIDE CARE. OKAY
THANK YOU- VIENNA. PLEASE COME.
FOR
MISTER CHAIR EMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT A. B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY
FOUR THE STUDENT HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND STREAMLINING
STREAMLINING ACT WHICH EXCESSES
STUDENT HOUSING IN SECURITY AND
STREAMLINES APPROVAL FOR STUDENT
HOUSING PLANS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COLLECT DATA ON STUDENT HOUSING
AND SECURITY. EACH OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES. BASIC NEEDS
CENTERS OR DEPARTMENT TASKED
WITH PROVIDING ON CAMPUS. AN OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS MORE EVER AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FOUR EXEMPTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT'SSTUDENT
HOUSING ARCHITECTURAL PLANS FROM
THE REQUIREMENT TO RECEIVE
APPROVAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES DGS AND THE
DIVISION OF THE STATE ARCHITECT
DSA. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR
THEREFORE CREATES PARITY BETWEEN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AD UC STUDENT
HOUSING ENSURING THAT NEED
HOUSING IS BUILT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. HERE IN IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS DOCTOR SLOWLY. AB
ISAAC CHANCELLOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA. OF CHANCELLOR OF
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. TESTWORK WITH THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF
THE RIVERSIDE COMING TO COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND IT'S THREE COLLEGES
OF MINE ABOUT NORCO IN RIVERSIDE
I AM TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR THE STUDENT
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND
STREAMLINING ACT. WE THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
PROVIDING FUNDING IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
BILL SB ONE SIXTY NINE FOR
PLANNING AND CONSTRUCTION OF
TWIN HOUSING OUT ALL PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN
THE STATE. THESE FUNDS WILL
ASSIST OUR COLLEGES IN PLANNING
FOR ON CAMPUS HOUSING. WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WAS FIRST BEING DEVELOPED
IN THE EARLY NINETEENTH CENTURY
MOST OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WERE LIVING AT HOME
WITH THEIR PARENTS WHILE
ATTENDING THEIR JUNIOR COLLEGES
. IN TWENTY TWENTY TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE ALL ARE OF
ALL AGES WITH A WITHOUT
DEPENDENT FROM THERE WITH
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS AND
EVOLVING TERRIERS. IN ADDITION
TO THE COST OF TUITION OUR
STUDENTS FACE ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES UP OFTEN BECOME
FORMIDABLE BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
HIGHER EDUCATION ESPECIALLY
AMONG THOSE WHO ARE NOT DISPUTED
TYPICAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. OF THE PAST. DURING
THE PAST FIVE YEARS INCREASED
DEMAND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS HAS
BECOME A SIGNIFICANT AND WHILE
ISSUE. THE STATE WIDE INVENTORY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
AVAILABLE FOR OUR STUDENTS IS
INADEQUATE. MORE AND MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
HOUSING INSECURE. CURRENT
DEFINITIONS FOR STUDENTS ARE OUT
OF DATE AND SHOULD BE UPDATED SO
THAT MORE STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN QUALIFY FOR HOUSING
VOUCHERS AND GRANTS PROGRAMS.
BASED ON RESURFACED AT COMING TO
COLLEGE DISTRICTS SURVEY RESULTS
VERY SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING. AT
EACH OF OUR CAMPUSES SURVEYS
ALSO SHOW THAT 18220% OF
STUDENTS WOULD CONSIDER FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT IF I'M ON CAP ON
CAMPUS HOUSING OPTION WHERE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WILL ADDRESS
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO OUR COLLEGES GUIDED
PATHWAYS HELP US TO BRIDGE OUR
STUDENTS TRANSITION TO FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES ALL CARRIERS. RCC
STUDENTS I'M NOT THE ONLY ONES
AFFECTED BY SHORTAGE. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING
THE SAME ISSUES. AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FOUR WILL HELP US DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE STUDENT HOUSING
POLICIES ACROSS THE STREET BY
INCLUDING THE COLLECTION OF
STUDENT HOUSING INSECURITY DATA
AT EACH OF OUR RESPECTIVE
CAMPUSES WITH SPECIAL ATTENTION
TO STUDENT PARENTS. LGBT Q. I A
AND OTHER UNDERSERVED GROUPS AND
ALLOWING THE EXEMPTION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
HOUSING ARCHITECTURAL PLANS FROM
THE REQUIREMENTS TO RECEIVE
APPROVAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES DIVISION OF
STATE ARCHITECT. THESE POLICIES
WILL HELP US ESTABLISH PARITY
WITH THE CSU'S AND USES ON
CAMPUS HOUSING. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY AND SHARE. RCB'S
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
FOUR CHRISTOPOULOS PARITY
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALL
STATE UNIVERSITIES AND THE UC
STUDENT HOUSING AND TO ENSURE
THAT MORE AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING IS BUILT. IN A TIMELY
MANNER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU CHANCELLOR ANY OTHER
WITNESS SUPPORT WITNESS- IN THE
ROOM. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO ANTELOPE VALLEY AND YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. GENEVIEVE COUNTY SHOW
FOR ON BEHALF OF DAN UP IN
SUPPORT. ANY OTHER IF NOT THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF HIS- B. L. A. B.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WITH YOUR ONLINE TWENTY ONE. ONE
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY WHAT ELSE
BEFORE. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. YES
YES. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME'S JOHN
SULLIVAN I TEACH ENGLISH AT
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE SANTIAGO
CANYON COLLEGE IN SAMBAR DINO
VALLEY COLLEGE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL MYSELF. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FORTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAROL
GOLDSMITH CHANCELLOR OF THE
COLLEGES THE STATE CENTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ON BEHALF OF
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE CLOTHES
COMMITTEE COLLEGE REEDLEY
COLLEGE AND MADERA COLLEGE. WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NO OTHER LINES IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. ANY NEW
PERSON WALKING IN. OKAY GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ALSO YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY THIS
COMMITTEE IS THE ONLY ONE WHICH
ALLOWS A TWEENER STATEMENTS- SO
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR OR ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM IN THAT CATEGORY.
NO ALL RIGHT THEN NO WE DON'T GO
INTO ANY WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IF NOT
THEN- EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
ANYONE ONE. TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
. SPEAKING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAIRPERSON MEDINA HOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SO ON
LET ME SEE BEFORE ARE YOU CLOSE
LET ME ASK OF MY- MEMBERS- IN
PRESENCE- WILL MAY HAVE A
QUESTION. NO OKAY THEN YOU CAN
GO AHEAD CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
STUDENTS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
COLLEGES OF THE NEED FOR STUDENT
HOUSING- FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
ASK- FOR EVERYONE'S I VOTE ON
THIS BILL. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS STILL WE ARE WAITING FOR
ALL I WANT TO ONE MORE PERSON TO
MORE PEOPLE. TWO MORE- OKAY
UNTIL WE FORMAL A QUORUM- ORDERS
JUST TO WAIT UNTIL THAT TIME AND
OR MOVE ON TO NEXT BILL.
CHAIRPERSON OF THE NIGHT YOU
HAVE A NEXT BILL. I THINK THANK
YOU. MISTER CHOI I I'M I'M SORRY
I DIDN'T HEAR BUT I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE A I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVED TO THE- NUMBER SIX IS
NOT YOURS. BUT I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND YEAH MOVED TO THE
OTHER AUTHORITY GRANTED.
SO MOVING BACK TO FILE ORDER. I
DON'T SEE- MR SANTIAGO HERE SO
WE WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM SEVEN
MISTER MAYOR CITRIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'LL MAKE THIS
QUICK THIS IS A WIN WIN WIN.
BILL A WIN FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES A WIN FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS IN OUR WIN WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY SERVE
AB NINETEEN FORTY TWO SEEKS TO
ADJUST THE COMMUNICABLE AS
FUNDING FORMULA TO RECOGNIZE THE
REALITIES. OF FIRST RESPONDERS
WHO- ENTER INTO AGREEMENTS WITH
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNICABLE AS IS
TO RECEIVE- THE FUNDING THAT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE IN ORDER
TO SUSTAIN THEIR THEIR PROGRAMS
WITH FIREFIGHTERS WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- TO- CONSTANTLY
UPDATE BASICALLY PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING. THROUGH
THEIR COMMUNICATORS. I
TESTIFYING HERE IN PERSON IS
YOUR WINDOWS MISTER CHAIR DR E.
SOCK. WITH THE RIVERSIDE
COMMUNICATORS DISTRICT. UNTIL.
WELCOME AGAIN AND YOU MAY
PASSAGE THANK YOU- CONTROLMEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT. AND
THE MODERN OF OTHER COLLEGES
BANK CLARK PUBLIC SAFETY
EDUCATION CENTER I'M TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
TWO. BUT ADDRESSES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FUNDING FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE AGREEMENT
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES. WE
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
FOR RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE
OF INSTRUCTION PROVIDED BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WORKING UNDER
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE AGREEMENTS
OR AYE ESSAYS NORMALLY CALLED
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES. WE
SUPPORT CHANGING THE FUNDING FOR
THIS TYPE OF TRAINING TO THE
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA USED FOR
INSTRUCTION IN CAREER
DEVELOPMENT AND COLLEGE
PREPARATION. RIVERSIDE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT. HOUSE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES DATING BACK TO NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE. CURRENT
PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF. COLIFORM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FIRE RIVERSIDE
CITY FIRE AND CORONA FIRE TO
NAME A FEW THIS LONGSTANDING
RELATIONSHIP HAS YIELDED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN BASIC OFFICERS
ACADEMIES NINETY SEVEN BASIC
CORRECTIONAL ACADEMIES FORTY
FOUR FIRE ACADEMIES TWENTY TWO
PARAMEDIC ACADEMIES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT AM P. ACADEMIES
PRODUCING AROUND TWENTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS EVERY YEAR
. COLLEGES WITH AYE S. H. HAVE
BEEN VOCAL ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF EQUITABLE FUNDING COLLEGES
WITH S. S. OFFER IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EXPENSIVE TO
RUN BUT ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MISSION TO
ADDRESS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
THAT LEADS TO HIGHER PAYING
CAREERS. WITH LIVABLE WAGES.
CURRENTLY I S. H. R. FUNDED
UNDER THE CREDIT PORTION OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. AND THAT THE STUDENTS
ARE CONSIDERED WORKING
PROFESSIONALS. IN THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THE STUDENTS DO NOT
EARN DEGREES OR- MOTIVATED FEW
FINANCIL AID. AS A RESULT OF
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
CHANGE WITH THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA THE BANK CLARK
PUBLIC SAFETY EDUCATION CENTER
UP MOANING ABOUT THE COLLEGE
DOES NOT RECEIVE ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THE STUDENT CENTER
. FINDING FORMULA FOR THE
STUDENTS BEYOND THE BASE. FIFTY
S. HOW FUNDING AT. FOUR THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN PER FTS
UNDER AB NINETEEN FORTY TWO. THE
CENTER WOULD RECEIVE A HIGHER
FUNDING RATES FOR FTS GENERATED
BY THESE TYPES OF AYE ASSAYS
USING THE CAREER DEVELOPMENT AND
COLLEGE PREPARATION FUNDING RATE
OF FIVE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN PER FTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ITS
REPLACEABLE AN IMPORTANT SERVICE
TO THE COMMUNITY. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AND SHARE
OUR DISTRICTS FOR SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY TWO TO HELP
RESOLVE THE EQUITABLE FUNDING
BUT HAVE BEEN VOICED BY OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. YEAH
IT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ACTUALLY MISTER CHAIR WERE WHAT
WE WERE SCHEDULED TO HAVE OF A
VIRTUAL- WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SO WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
AND THEN THEN I'LL CALL FOR
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO
MISTER MODERATOR WE COULD GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR THE OTHER
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU A
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN DENIED HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
DOCTOR BERRY GRAFTON'S PRESIDENT
OF LOS ANGELES VALLEY COLLEGE
I'M HONORED TO JOIN YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC TO CHEAT
REPRESENTING CHANCELLOR
FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ AND THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARTUCCI MENTION THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE CRITICAL ISSUE OF
SUPPORTING TRAINING FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. PRIOR TO BECOMING
PRESIDENT I HAD THE GREAT
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ONE
CRITICAL PRINCIPLE THAT THIS
EXPERIENCE TAUGHT ME WAS THAT
YOU NEVER SEVEN PERSONNEL INTO A
SITUATION IF THEY'RE NOT
PROPERLY TRAINED AND EQUIPPED.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TRAIN 80% OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMTS HI ASSAYS
ARE AT THE HEART OF THIS
PROVIDING TRAINING FOR NEW
RECRUITS AS WELL AS CURRENT
PROFESSIONALS. THE STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING FOR BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE FROM RIVERSIDE
MANSION WAS AN IMPORTANT POLICY
POLICY SHIFT BUT IT DID NOT
ACCOUNT FOR AND SEE STUDENTS
COLLEGES OFFERING THIS TYPE OF
TRAINING AT THE REIMBURSEMENT
CUT THIRTY PERCENT. FRAWLEY C.
CITY'S LARGEST COLLEGE E. LACK
THE ICY PROGRAM AT PRE PANDEMIC
ENROLLMENTS OF OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS A YEAR EDDIE
LACK APPROXIMATELY 50% OF THEIR
ICY PROGRAM PROVIDES TRAINING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT 25% FOR
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMTS AND THE
REMAINING 25% FOR THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND PROBATION. READ
LOST PER. FOR FISCAL YEAR TWO
THREE. IS FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. WE QUITE SIMPLY
CANNOT PROVIDE THE QUALITY OF
TRAINING DEMANDED. PROPERLY
PREPARE THESE FIRST RESPONDERS
WITHOUT THE ADJUSTMENTS CALLED
FOR NAY PYI NINETEEN FORTY TWO.
AS THE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY TWO LACC RESPECTS
PERSPECTIVE- URGES ARRIVAL ON
THIS MUCH NEEDED MEASURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NOW
WILL GO TO OTHERS IN FAVOR- IN
THE HEARING ROOM. NAME IN THE
GROUP YOU'RE WITH. NOT ONLY IS
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
SPONSORED THE MEASURE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE PALO
VERDE ANTELOPE VALLEY- SAN
DIEGO. AND SAMPOERNA DINO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOR
THE FIRST TIME LINE FORTY TWO.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU- FOR
HAVING ME THIS IS CAROL GOLD
AGAIN CHANCELLOR OF THE STATE
CENTER COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
BEHALF OF EVERYONE AT FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE YEAH FRESNO COUNTY
SHERIFF FRESNO COUNTY PD AND
FIRE WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND WE- YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
THIRTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
AUDIBLE OF FAMILY MEN AND WOMEN
MY NAME IS DR- MORE TOWARDS ANY
SYSTEM SUPERINTENDENT VICE
PRESIDENT OF INSTRUCTION AT
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS I WOULD
LIKE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE SUPPORT AB NINETEEN FORTY
TWO. INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE
AGREEMENTS ENHANCE OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY RISKS AND BENEFITS- BUT
JUST YOUR NAME AND OBSERVATION
ON THAT'S IT ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
GO TO THE NEXT PERSON. NAME OR
NUMBER OF ALLIANCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR MISTER. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR.
NO NOT NOT ON THE PHONE AT THIS
TIME WILL GO TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE AT&T MODERATOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. AS STATED POSITION
OF OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN USING
YOUR PHONE WE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. ANY
WITNESSES IN IN THE- TWEENER
POSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SCENE NINE MISTER MODERATOR ANY.
WINNERS ON THE LINE. IF YOUR
POSITION IS TWEENER FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C.
NINE TO THE CHAIR I'M SORRY TO
THE AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIYANKA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. EIGHT
MISTER SALAS. PLEASE- ACCEPT MY
APOLOGIES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BRIDGET OF THAT AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A PRESENT BEFORE YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL WE WERE STARTING
WITH NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. IN
START WITH A NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MEMBERS ON THIS BILL SHOULD BE-
VERY FAMILIAR TO ALL OF YOU I
BELIEVE EVERYONE VOTED FOR THIS
ALREADY- THIS BILL IS A RE
INTRODUCTION OF A BILL THAT WE
ALL VOTED ON. LAST YEAR- BUT
THIS ONE ADDRESSES THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE. AB
DANCING SIXTY THREE- WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
PURCHASING GENE SYNTHESIS
PRODUCTS FROM RESPONSIBLE ACTORS
WHO TAKE BIO SECURITY. AND THE
SAFETY OF OUR COUNTRY SERIOUSLY.
AS SCIENTISTS HAVE SHOWN THAT IT
IS POSSIBLE TO RECONSTRUCT
VIRUSES LIKE THE COMMON NINETEEN
HANDY BOWLER BY USING MAIL
ORDER. DNA THAT CAN BE PURCHASED
THROUGH THE INTERNET FROM GENE
SYNTHESIS COMPANIES. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE NO REQUIREMENTS THAT
GENE SYNTHESIS COMPANIES NEED TO
SCREEN THEIR CUSTOMERS OR THEIR
ORDERS TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
NOT CRIMINALS WHO MIGHT BE
PURCHASING GENE SEQUENCES. THAT
COULD BE ASSEMBLED INTO A DEADLY
PATHOGEN. A BECAUSE OF THE
BECAUSE THE STATE FUNDS MUCH OF
THE UNIVERSITY RESEARCH ABOUT
THE CS USING UC'S IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS SUPPORT REASONABLE
GENE SYNTHESIS SYNTHESIS
COMPANIES. WHEN THEY PURCHASE
RESEARCH PRODUCTS FROM THEM-
WITH THAT MR CHERRY DO HAVE-
TESTIMONY WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF
DR GIGI A SENIOR SCHOLAR AT JOHN
HOPKINS. CENTER FOR HEALTH
SECURITY. AND I BELIEVE I ALSO
HAVE- DR GREGORY A COUPLE
INCISORS HERE PROFESSOR AND
DIRECTOR OF THE BIODEFENSE
GRADUATE PROGRAM AT GEORGE MASON
UNIVERSITY. BOTH BOTH ON THE
LINE YES OKAY SO MISTER
MODERATOR IF WE GO TO THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. ON THE
LINE PLEASE. THANK YOU THOSE
LINES ARE OPEN. EIGHT THIS IS
YOUR GRANDPA CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
. OKAY GREAT- WELL THE GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
ENTRUSTING BIO SECURITY CONCERNS
ABOUT GENE SYNTHESIS OF THE
SPELL AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER MY SUPPORT-
I'M HE GRUMBLED AND EFFECTIVE
PROFESSOR AT THE JOHNS HOPKINS
CENTER FOR HEALTH SECURITY IN
THE BLOOMBERG SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- I AM MY BACKGROUND IS
AND- BIOSCIENCES NICER BONTA
FEDERAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
NIH AND- MERGING BIOTECH AND
SECURITY. AND ALSO SERVED AS A
COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NATIONAL ACADEMIES
REPORT ON BIODEFENSE IN AGES
THAT ECOLOGY AND WE CONCLUDED
THAT ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING BY
SECURITY WITH WE FACE. IS THAT A
BAD ACTOR COULD USE GENE
SYNTHESIS PRODUCTS CAN MAKE PATH
THAT PROFESSIONALLY- SMALL
VIRUSES SH AND THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD REQUIRE THAT- THAT ONLY
RESPONSIBLE COMPANIES- THAT
SCREEN ORDERS BE USED BY
CUSTOMERS- UNDER THE BELT SO
SHOULD MAKE IT HARDER FOR
NEFARIOUS ACTORS TO ACT AT THE
GENETIC MATERIAL NEEDED TO BE-
TO MAKE VIRUSES LIKE SMALLPOX.
OR FULLER IMPORT THEM AND- WE
KNOW ABOUT THE ON GOING BECAUSE
THE NINETEENTH AND DEMOCRATS-
WHAT THE CLEAR DEMONSTRATION
THAT IS OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN AND
BY THE AFFECTED BY HEALTH
SECURITY CRISIS- MANY-
COMMERCIAL JEAN CITIZENS
COMPANIES ALREADYVOLUNTARILY
SCREEN ORDERS BUT AS THAT COST
MONEY THOSE. RESPONSIBLE
COMPANIES LARGELY IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS WELL AS ELSEWHERE IN
THE WEST HAVE BEEN AT A
COMPETITIVE BUSINESS
DISADVANTAGED AND SUCH BUT THAT
THAT LEGISLATION WILL LET LEVEL
THE GLOBAL PLAYING FIELD BUT
THAT ONLY HIGH QUALITY
ORGANIZATION TAKE PART IN THIS
EMERGING FIELD. IT'S MY HOPE
THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS THE WAY
FOR U. S. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OTHER GOVERNMENTS TO PUT
REGULATIONS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT DNA SYNTHESIS PRODUCTS DO
NOT FALL INTO THE WRONG HANDS
THANK YOU. THE COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING HERE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP TO GUARD AGAINST
BY A SECURITY THREAT AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU AND
MISTER MODERATOR. WE GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
THAT LINE OF THE- THIS IS GREAT
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME
IS. ON THE SOCIAL. THANK YOU- IT
AND THEY YOU FOR AT THE HEARING
TODAY- I'M ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
AND DIRECTOR OF THE BOTTOM
INSTRUCTOR PROGRAM AT THE SHORE
SCHOOL POLICY GOVERNMENT AT
GEORGE MASON UNIVERSITY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN I BRIEFED UNITED
NATIONS SECURITY COUNCIL ON HOW
NICE IT ACTORS COULD USE
ADVANCES IN SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY. CONFLICT MASS
CASUALTIES HEY I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE SITE IS WORKING
GROUP AND BIOLOGICAL CHEMICAL
SECURITY AT THE CENTER FOR ARMS
CONTROL NONPROLIFERATION
DEDICATED TO PREVENTING THE
MISUSE OF BIOLOGY CHEMISTRY.
BIOLOGY'S A POWERFUL TECHNOLOGY
THAT THE POTENTIAL RIGHT TO GIVE
HIM BENEFITS. HOWEVER THIS
TECHNOLOGY COULD ALSO ALLOW A
MALICIOUS ORRECKLESS ACTOR
GREAT THINKERS PATHOGENS SUCH AS
SMALLPOX. FROM BEING MADE AT THE
ORDER ONLINE. NO COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD INCLUDING UNITED STATES
REQUIRES A COMPANY THAT SELLS
THE PRODUCT IN A TO SCREEN THE
CUSTOMER'S. ENTERTAINING ORDERS
TO ENSURE THEY'RE NOT PROVIDING
MATERIAL THAT CAN BE SUBMITTED
INTO A DANGEROUS PATHOGENS. A
GROUP OF COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE
SYNTHETIC DNA HAVE CREATED THE
INTERNATIONAL GENE SYNTHESIS
CONSORTIUM OR IDEAS SEE. DOES
RECORDSMEMBERS DISCRETE ORDERS
AND CUSTOMERS TO PREVENT THE
MISUSE OF THE PRODUCTS. HOWEVER
THESE CUTS THIS GROUP REPRESENTS
ONLY ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT. OF
THE COMMERCIAL GENE SYNTHESIS
CAPACITY WORLDWIDE. THIS MEANS
THAT THERE ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF
COMPANIES ARE ABLE SOUTH
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS GENETIC
MATERIAL TO THE PARISH ACTORS
WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT. AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE WHEN UP
CLOSES BY SECURITY GAP BY
REQUIRING CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES. REQUESTING
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM TO
ONLY PURCHASE GENE SYNTHESIS
PRODUCTS FROM COMPANIES THAT ARE
MEMBERS OF I JUST. AND EVELYN
FIVE SKINNY SCREENING.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
ENGAGING CUTTING EDGE BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH AND THEIR LARGE
PURCHASERS OF SYNTHETIC DNA
GIVING THEM SIGNIFICANT
PURCHASING POWER THAT CAN HELP
PROMOTE BIO SECURITY. IN THE
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
MAKE TO THE GROWING BIOECONOMY
AB NINETEEN SIXTY THREE HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO ESTABLISH A DE
pFACTO NATIONAL FIVE SECURITY
STANDARD PROCESS THAT BIOLOGY. I
CAN OTHER ISSUE OFFICIALS SEE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
COME AT LEADER THE FIELD BY
SECURITY. BY BECOMING THE FIRST
STATE TO REQUIRE THAT GENE
SYNTHESIS COMPANIES WHICH DO
BUSINESS WITH PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
DEMONSTRATE THE COMMENDED BY A
SECURITY. MISTER SUPPORT AB
NINETEEN SIX THREE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S BY SECURITY BY
REQUIRING THAT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ONLY PURCHASE
SYNTHETIC DNA. RESPONSIBLE
COMPANIES UP ALL STREET BY
STREET GREEN PRACTICES TO
PREVENT THE EXTERNAL RECKLESS OR
MALICIOUS MISUSE OF THIS
IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IN THE ROOM MARIENWERDER C.
NINE- MISTER MODERATOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS STAR THEN ZERO I APOLOGIZE
THE NUMBER ONE AND ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OR NO LINES IN
Q. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE
MISTER MODERATOR OF THEIR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ANY WITNESSES WHO
ARE TWEETERS IN THE HEARING ROOM
. AND SEE NINE MISTER MODERATOR
ANY TWEETERS ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU YOUR POSITION IS
TWEENER ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A LINE
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
OUR GARMENT COMES FROM LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS MERRY MORE OIL WITH
THE HEAT CSU WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON ON THE BILL BUT WE
ARE PLANNING TO WORK WITH THE
DOCTOR ON THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THIS MODERATOR ANY OTHER
TWEETERS ON THE LINE. NOT NOT
NOT AT THIS TIME SIR THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C. NINE
IF- MISTER SALAS SHE'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
PRIVATE WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A SECOND
BILL TO PRESENT THAT'S CORRECT-
FILE ITEM NINE A. B. NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. CORRECT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FIRST LET ME START
BY SAYING THAT ARE WE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
WELL I THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THE BILL- PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE
UCCS USE A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
REPORT ON STUDENT OUTCOMES OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON THEIR
CAMPUSES. AND HOW MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING IS BEING SPENT- THIS
COMES BY WAY OF AN L. A. OVER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IS
A REPORT. THAT WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THREE HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS ALLUC'S ALL
CSU'S AT LEAST 75% OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
PROVIDE SOME FORM OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON CAMPUS.
RECENTLY THE LEGISLATORS SUB
SUPPLEMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY AND- THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
FIFTEEN POINT THREE MILLION WAS
PROVIDED TO THE UC CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HAVE FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET THE AMOUNT HAS
INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY TO SIXTY
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- THIS GROWTH IS IN
RESPONSE TO THE GROWING CONCERN
OVER STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
NATIONWIDE 60% OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS. FILL THE PANDEMIC MADE
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO ACCESS
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. THE
PREVALENCE OF DEPRESSION AMONG
OUR STUDENTS AS INCREASED.
ANXIETY HAS INCREASED AND THEIR
ACADEMIC- PERFORMANCE HAS.
DECREASED THE NEEDS TO ENSURE
THAT MENTAL SPENDING IS BEING
SPENT AND USE IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE TO
IMPROVE STUDENT WELL BEING. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN REQUIRES
THE YOU SEE THE CSU AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO SUBMIT A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT BY MARCH
FIRST TEACHER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATURE.
ON THE USE OF FUNDS ALLOCATED
FOR STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- WITH THAT I DO HAVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I HAVE-
MISS JASMINE PRASAD A STUDENT AT
FOLSOM LAKE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONCE
AGAIN- THE FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ADVOCATING MORE FUNDING TOWARDS
MENTAL HEALTH AND LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. AND SECOND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
FOR CONTINUING HIS ADVOCACY
WITHIN HIGHER EDUCATION AND
TRULY LISTEN TO STUDENTS. MENTAL
HEALTH IS NOT A NEW PARTY. IT'S
A CONTINUING ISSUE THAT AFFECTS
STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL PATHWAY.
80% OF STUDENTS TO NOT HAVE
INCREASE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES DURING THE FIRST YEAR
THE PANDEMIC. STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE CONSISTENTLY ASK FOR
MORE MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELLING.
AND TO HELP DURING THE NEW
ISOLATED ENVIRONMENTS. ARE UNDER
. MCKNIGHT MINORITY STUDENT
POPULATION OR MOST AFFECTED BY
THE LACK OF ACCESSIBILITY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC MY
ANXIETY AND ADHD HAVE ONLY
WORSENED MY PEERS CONTINUE TO GO
THROUGH THE SAME STRUGGLES. AND
THEY OFTEN ASK HOW THE FUNDS ARE
BEING DISTRIBUTED TO ADDRESS THE
STRUGGLES. LIKELY I AM THANKFUL
TO ATTEND A COLLEGE THAT HAS
INCREASED AFFORDABLE RESOURCES
TO HELP STUDENTS OBTAIN MENTAL
INSTABILITY HOWEVER THIS IS NOT
THE SAME FOR EVERY CAMPUS.
TRANSPARENCY ALLOWS THE
LEGISLATURE AND STUDENTS TO SEE
WHAT SPECIFIC AREAS STILL NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED AS WELL AS HOW
EACH COLLEGE IS WORKING TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS APPROPRIATELY.
STUDENTS ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN
COLLEGES INCREASE THEIR LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES IN ORDER TO SEE
OUR STUDENTS RE ENROLL IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WE MUST SHOW NEED
BASED DATA. AND FOR THIS REASON
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I THOUGH
ON AB NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. MISTER SALAS YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS- ARE. NOT I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE ON THE
LINE BECAUSE. WITNESS AND
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. DO WE HAVE
A NAME I COULD LOOK FOR. NO OKAY
BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE HAVE
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
MISTER MODERATOR IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE LINE. G. TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
UNTIL ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAUL YODER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL OR TONIGHT VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ELEVEN. HI THIS IS MAGGIE
MERIT REPRESENTING THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. FIFTY ONE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. I APOLOGIZE LINE FIFTY
ONE DISCONNECTED NO OTHER LINES
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE. STATE OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NO
LINES IN Q. ANY ANY TWEETERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR OF THEIR
ANY TWEEN YEARS ON THE LINE.
MMHM THE STATE A POSITION OF
TWEENER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. LISTY THANK YOU- TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS MR
WITH DIALOGUE FIRST I WANT TO-
THANK YOU FOR THIS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY AND WE WE'VE JUST
HEARD IT MENTAL HEALTH IS A HUGE
ISSUE FOR OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY. DURING THE PANDEMIC
BIRD HEARING THAT- THAT I'M
HEARING IT ALL THROUGH OF MY
DISTRICT AT THE BUT I REALLY
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE
DON'T JUST KEEP THROWING. MONEY
AT THE PROBLEM SO I LOVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I THINK
YOU'VE COVERED A LOT OF THOSE
REALLY IMPORTANT METRICS WITH
YOUR BILL THE ONE THING THAT OF
THE EVENTUALLY WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MEASURE IS THE
QUALITY OF THE COUNSELING THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE. RECEIVING AND
HOW YOU MEASURE TRUE OUTCOMES
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW YOU'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT MAKING SURE THAT
THESE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED A
TIMELY MANNER AND- YOU KNOW FOR
THAT FOR THAT FOR THE ENTIRE
DURATION. OF WHEN THEY NEED HELP
THAT CITY IT WOULD BE NICE I
THINK AND I MEAN NOT JUST FOR
STUDENTS BUT ACROSS THE STATE IF
WE CAN FIGURE OUT. YOU KNOW HOW
HOW MUCH IS THIS HOW MUCH IS ALL
THE SPENDING OR DOING OF REALLY
MAKING A DIFFERENCE THAT'S
THAT'S A QUESTION WILL HAVE TO
EVENTUALLY CANCER BUT IT'S- I'VE
I'VE DEALT PRECIADO BRINGING
FORWARD. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT YEAH WE BELIEVE IN
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCREASING
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY THAN THE WE
LIKE ALL FORMS OF GOVERNMENT
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT EFFICACY AND
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DOLLARS ARE BEING TARGETED THE
WAY THEY NEED TO SO THAT WE HAVE
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE DESIRE.
SUFFICIENT THAT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE- SEEN NONE- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
SALAS. I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY BUT WHEN TIMES
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. I THANK.
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE-
MEMBERS BY THE COMMITTEE. AS
REFLECTED ON PAGE FIVE. OF THE
ANALYSIS AND ASK THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN THE SEGMENTS. IN
ADDRESSING THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THAT THE REPORT IS RELEASED. AND
WE WILL VOTE WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF GOING BACK
IN FILE- ORDER. WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM TO. MR SANTIAGO IF
YOU'RE READY.
SORT OF THE. THANK YOU MISTER
TRIPLE WHAMMY TO PRESENT ON THIS
AND- HE BEAT- SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO ADD THIS BILL REALLY ISN'T
JUST ABOUT. SETTING ASIDE
EQUALITY IN TALKING ABOUT EQUITY
AND PARITY FOR PART TIME FACULTY
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S REALLY
ABOUT IT ABOUT EQUAL PAY FOR
EQUAL WORK NOW I I'VE NEVER
TAUGHT A COMMITTEE CALLED- I
TAUGHT A MIDDLE SCHOOLS UNITED
HAVE HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT. IN AT AT
THE TIME I WAS ALSO WORKING- ON
AN HOURLY BASIS I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THAT THAT THE SAME PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE HAVING NOW- WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS
WHO ARE HAVING TO WORK ON A PART
TIME BASIS NOT EQUALLY PAID.
WHETHER NOT COMPENSATED FOR
OFFICE HOURS NOT COMPENSATED- TO
MAKE SURE THE EDUCATION COMPLETE
WHEN THEY'RE HELPING STUDENTS
NOT COMPENSATED FOR- HELPING TO
REVIEW- MATERIAL THAT HAS BEEN
ASSIGNED AND OR PREP SO THERE IS
A TERRIBLE AND AGREE NOT JUST ON
PAPER BUT IN TERMS OF. WHAT IS
PAY FOR WHAT IS NOT PAID FOR SO
WHAT WE'RE ASKING HERE'S A PART
TIME IN THIS BILL THAT THAT PART
TIME INSTRUCTORS BE PAID TO
PARITY. AND THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THEY'RE PAID. AT
LEAST AT THE SAME RACIAL IS FULL
TIME FACULTY FOR THE VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD SIMPLE BILL
BECAUSE OF IT BECAUSE WE NEED TO
DO THIS- TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
GET THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE THEY-
EIGHT. A. N. A STRICTER TEACHER.
WHO WHO IS ABLE TO DO THESE
THINGS APPROPRIATELY. TRANSLATES
DIRECTLY TO A BETTER QUALITY OF%
EDUCATION THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
PROLONGS THE PERCENT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES WE HAVE
TO- DOCTOR MORE WILL BE
TESTIFIED BY PHONE. AND MS
WALKER WHO WILL BE HERE IF- ANY
QUESTIONS SHOULD BE COME UP.
OKAY SO WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
THEN- MISTER MODERATOR. IT'S-
DOCTOR MORE CORRECT THANK YOU
YOU. BEDLINER. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BACK JOHN
MORRISON ON THE PART TIME
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR OF HUMAN
SERVICES AT LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE. THANK YOU SEE WOMEN
THANK YOU HAVE A FOR SUPPORTING
OUR TOPICS EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL
WORK- EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK.
IN JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND NINE
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA TOOK A
HISTORIC STEP IN PROTECTING
AMERICAN WORKERS WHEN HE SIGNED
UP BUILDING THAT THEY'RE FAIR
PAY ACT THE FIRST PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION. YOU DON'T LAWS
CAN CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE WHERE
EMPLOYERS UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO HAVE THE
AWARENESS AND TO TAKE THE
NECESSARY ACTION TO CREATE
POLICY IN PRACTICE FOR FAIR
COMPENSATION. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THE HEARING I'M GOING TO USE THE
DISCIPLINE DISCIPLINE CHARACTER
MAKES TO DEMONSTRATE OUR POINT.
YES FABULOUS OF COURSE EITHER.
BRAND ABOUT PASSING OR AVOIDED
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE. THE
RELEVANT TIME IN CALCULUS IS
INFLECTION POINT. AN INSPECTION
POINT PLEASANT POINT ON THE
CURVE THAT SEPARATES A CONCAVE
UPWARD TROMBA COUNTY SANTA WENT
AND VICE VERSA AS DEMONSTRATED
ON THE HANDOUT YOU'VE RECEIVED.
ALSO THE FOUNDED THE MOMENT
CONNECTICUT CHANGE OCCURS OR MAY
OCCUR. DOES AT COUNTY CORK.
NUMBER DOCUMENT YOU RECEIVED WAS
CREATED BASED UPON FROM THE
WEBSITE CALLED MATHIS PHONE.
SEPARATELY AND DISTINCTLY THIS
HANDOUT MEANS TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS TO A FULL TIME
PROFESSIONAL AND A PART TIME
PROFESSOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE PROGRAM
PROFESSOR GETS PAID TO TEACH
STUDENTS IN A TWO HOUR LECTURE
COURSE EACH WEEK ABOUT THE
CONTENT OF THIS PLANT OUT. AND
SO DOES A PART TIME PROFESSOR.
FULL TIME PROFESSOR GETS PAID
FOR THE TIME TO DEVELOP A LESSON
PLAN AROUND THAT SENT OUT. A
PART TIME PROFESSOR THAT'S NOT.
THE FULL TIME PROFESSOR GETS
PAID FOR THE TIME YOU TO DEVELOP
ACTIVITIES STUDENT WORK AND
WORKSHEET. ABSOLUTELY USED TO
PRACTICE THE CONTENT ON THE TENT
OUT. THAT PART KIND OF PENSIONS
. NOT THE FULL TIME PROFESSOR
GETS PAID FOR THE TIME USED TO
GREAT MID TERMS AND FINALS FOR
THEIR CALCULUS COURSE. THE PART
TIME PROFESSORS THE- PART TIME
PROFESSORS WANT EQUAL PAY FOR
EQUAL WORK. TRANSACTION GOING ON
UNDERSTANDING A. B. SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO TIMES ON THE
DIFFERENCES DEMONSTRATED IN ONE
SIMPLE CAPITALIST MUCH. BUT KEEP
THE SAME LESSON IN THE SAME
COURSE ON THE SAME. TWO
DIFFERENT INSTRUCTORS ARE PAID
IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS. QUITE
SIMPLY THAT PAID PRACTICE NEEDS
TO SEE. THE TIME HAS COME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE EQUAL PAY A
REALITY FOR EDUCATORS IN THE
LARGEST POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD. I'M VERY
DISCARDED AS UNPRECEDENTED
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY NOTHING.
NOTHING COULD BE MORE IMPORTANT
IN ENSURING ALL WORKERS RECEIVE
EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK. NUMBER
TWENTY TWO APPLICTION POINT.
BROUGH BONTA SAID IT DEPENDS ON
. ON THE CHOICES WE MAKE
PARTICULARLY ACCERN INFLECTION
POINTS IN HISTORY. RELATED WITH
BIG CHANGES ARE HAPPENING AND
EVERYTHING SEEMS UP FOR GRABS.
NOW WE ALL HAVE LIVED IN A WORLD
THAT HAS GEARED UP FOR GRABS FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS. WE SIMPLY
WANT EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK.
AS I SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF MY
STATEMENT I'M AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR TEACHING SERVICES AT
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE. UNLIKE
THE CALCULUS PROFESSOR THE
EXAMPLE. I AM ONLY PAID FOR THE
TIME IN THE CLASSROOM PROVIDING
DIRECT INSTRUCTION BUT NOT FOR
ANY OTHER INSTRUCTIONAL ACTIVITY
. I'M HERE TODAY THE REQUESTED
SUPPORT AND PROHIBITING THIS
PRACTICE. BUT WE DESERVE EQUAL
PAGE FOR EQUAL WORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE PRACTICE. THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE JUST HAD SOME OF OUR
TECHNICAL. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
PARTICULAR WITH THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
ABOUT. THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SIR ALSO
MISTER MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WHEN A CO SPONSORED THE
BILL ALSO- HERE STRONG SUPPORTER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE'RE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GENEVIEVE COUNTY SHOW
FOR ON BEHALF OF JOHN UP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. JOHNSON FOR
SAUDI SINCE I'M FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATORS WERE IN HIGH
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YES. REMIND WITNESSES
THAT THEY HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE RHYME MACKLIN
ANY OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AGO
CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING ON
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SAYS SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS- WE
ARE RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION FOR IF
TO THIS BILL YOU KNOW FIRST WE
DO WANT TO STRONGLY SAY WE
IDENTIFY WITH THE BECAUSE OF
THAT THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE- IS TRYING TO FIX
WHICH IS WE REALLY DO NEED TO
COMPENSATE ARE PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBERS BETTER AND CREATE BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY WITHOUT A
COMMENSURATE- SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
INCREASE WE DO NOT THINK THAT
THIS BILL WILL FIX THE PROBLEM
THAT IS THAT FACES OUR
INSTITUTIONS TODAY- RIGHT NOW.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES RECEIVE THE
LOWEST PER PUPIL FUNDING RATE OF
ANY EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE
STATE. THAT FORCES HARD CHOICES
FOR OUR DISTRICTS TO SATISFY
BOTH LOCAL AND DISTRICT
PRIORITIES. JUST SOME EXAMPLES
FOR YOU- YOU KNOW WITHOUT AN
INCREASE IN PAY OR INCREASE IN
BUDGET- THIS WOULD FORCE A HARD
DECISION ON YOU KNOW INCREASES
AND CURRENT FACULTY PAY. HOW TO
MEET PENSION OBLIGATIONS FOR
CURRENT STAFF- OTHER CATEGORICAL
THAT DO BENEFIT- PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBERS IT WOULDN'T
CREATE HARD CHOICES ON. PROGRAMS
THAT WE KNOW IF- STUDENT
ENROLLMENT- AND CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS- FOR EXAMPLE- FREE TUITION
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS-
BASIC NEED FUNDING TO ALLEVIATE
FOOD AND HOUSING INSECURITY AND
JUST A LOT MORE- THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE ALL I THINK AGREE ARE
CRITICAL FOR STUDENTS AND
FACULTY AND STAFF. AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE RESTORE
SPECTRALLY OPPOSED AND- WOULD
ASK FOR NO ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING-
NINE- ANY TWEETERS ON THIS BILL
. IN THE HEARING ROOM C. NINE H.
WINNERS ON THE OF PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
COULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
POSITION OF TWEENER PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q. LINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC COUNTY
MAGGIE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT AND I
TEACH MATH DOWNTURN ANTONIO
COLLEGE- I WISH TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE. FORTY FRIEND THE
WATER AGING WISH AT CYPRESS
COLLEGE IN THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION AND I
FERVENTLY SUPPORT AB. SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT. THANK
YOU. M. LINE FIFTY TWO. I'M HERE
IN ROBERT PARK WHEN FACULTY OF
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE. AND
THEN THE NUMBER OF CPA NCTA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NOT BLIND.
TWENTY SEVEN. HOME OF THE LINE
TWENTY ONE. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
SULLIVAN I AM AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR TEACHING ENGLISH AT
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE SANTIAGO
CANYON COLLEGE AND SAN MARINO
VALLEY COLLEGE AND LET'S SEE
HERE SECRETARY AND I SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE FIFTY FOUR. MEDINA
MEMBERS DAVID HAWKINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
THEN THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK OF FAMILY
MEMBERS SANTIAGO PROPERTY THIS
BILL OUR VERY MAKING. EVERY.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR.
ALEX ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR THANKS
DELTA COLLEGE ALSO- NORTON PART
TIME DIRECTOR FOR CCA IN STRONG
WHAT ABOUT THE SEVENTEEN. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE. FORTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME'S GEORGE ASHFORD-
ON BEHALF OF GENERATION UP IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
THAT WE REPRESENT- I MISTRUST
RESTAURANT PART OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THE PROBLEM LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THIS RUN
EARLIER I HAD FORGOTTEN TO ASK
FOR WOODS IN SUPPORT I WOULD ASK
FOR TWEETERS SO I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR TWEETERS THE WHAT A
MESS ANYBODY. DIRT OKAY GOOD IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR
POSITION OF TWEENER PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. WE ALSO
HAVE LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS JOHN AUSUBEL
FROM JP COLLEGE BY SPEAKING
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO. WE HAVE ANOTHER LINE
BUT IT'S WITH AN OPERATOR IN
JUST A MOMENT. COMMENT IS FROM
LINE FORTY FIVE. FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- HIM BACK THE
IDEA ON HOW THE UC STUDENT ON
SOMEONE AND THEN THEY CAN KERN
ROMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL AND ON
BEHALF OF THE GENERATION. I'M
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU. NO FURTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME AND MR
MODERATOR IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
LINE. THANK YOU THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU'LL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NONE TO MR SANTIAGO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE- YEAH I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON THE
BILL STRAIGHT FOR EQUAL PAY FOR
EQUAL WORK IT'S COMMON SENSE-
PARTICULARLY IN TODAY'S ERA AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ADULT. I
I'D LIKE TO THANK MR SANTIAGO
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD
TODAY. AND AS MANY OF YOU MAY
KNOW I WAS ALSO LIKE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. ADJUNCT PROFESSOR SO I
KNOW VERY WELL THE STRUGGLES OF
THESE PROFESSIONALS WHO I THINK
ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THE
STRUGGLES THEY FACE SOMETIMES IS
TRYING TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE.
I THINK IT'S THE JOB OF THE
POLICY COMMITTEE TO SET POLICY
AND I THINK EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL
WORK IS ABOUT AS BASIC AS IT
GETS. SO HERE ARE OTHER FORMS
IN THERE WILL BE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO TALK ABOUT THE
COST IMPACT OF THESE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL. BUT
LIKE MR SANTIAGO I- I THINK THIS
IS AS BASIC AS IT GETS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE- FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS. RGH I WAS GONNA
SAY WE HAD A QUORUM AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A VOTE OKAY BUT SINCE
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM- WELL
THANK YOU AND WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE WHEN WE DO HAVE A QUIET
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
AND WITH THAT WILL CONTINUE-
FILE ORDER WITH- FILE ITEM
TWELVE- THAT BE MYSELF BUT I'M
I'M IN I'M IN IS SKIP THAT AND
GO TO. MISTER CALDERON. FILE
ITEM. THIRTEEN WELCOME IS
CALDERON. THANK YOU AIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH A WELLNESS VENDING
MACHINE PILOT PROGRAM AT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE TO
ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE SUFFICIENT
ACCESS TO HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PRODUCTS STUDENTS FACE SEVERAL
BARRIERS ACCESSING HEALTH CARE
PRODUCTS ON CAMPUS FOR EXAMPLE
MANY STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS ARE
NOT OPEN TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND
MAX SAME DAY APPOINTMENTS OTHERS
ARE CLOSED ON WEEKENDS AND SOME
DO NOT HAVE A CENTER AT ALL. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO WILL
ALLOW STUDENTS TO ACCESS
DISCOUNTED OVER THE COUNTER
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PRODUCTS.
OUT SIDE PHARMACY HOURS WITHOUT
NEEDING TO LEAVE THEIR CAMPUS. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD UC RIVERSIDE AT UC
DAVIS AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AT CSU AND CCC FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE SAID THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
REYES AND THEN HOUSES. WITH ME
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY TWO IS ELIZABETH COME ON
IN A RECENT UC RIVERSIDE
GRADUATE AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD
GENERATION ACTION ALUMINUM I WHO
WILL BE CALLING IN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
ALLIED ASSAULT. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. PERFECT
THANK YOU. WHEN YOU GO THE I AM
YOU THINK AND- WHAT NOT I WAS
OUT OF THE COALITION NOT
ESTABLISHED ALONG WITH EXPRESS
SPENDING MACHINE AT THE UC ON
CAMPUS. THE GOAL OF THIS MACHINE
WAS- THAT UC RIVERSIDE STUDENTS
HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
HEALTHCARE ON CAMPUS- DEFENDING
MACHINE MAKES IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
CHOICES ABOUT THEIR BODIES AND
THEIR HEALTH BY CLOSING ANY GAPS. AND AVOIDING ANY BARRIERS THAT
ARISE. BUT IN DESERVE THE FIFTH
I. CUMPLIR ONLY ON CAMPUS AND A
CALL. B. C. RIVERSIDE MACHINE
PROVED TO BE SUCCESSFUL- IN
PROVIDING THESE ITEMS AT A LOW
COST. AND SHOWED US THAT THERE
REALLY WAS A GAP IN ACCESSING
THESE MATERIALS. SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN- MISSING CLASS
OR WORK TO BUY HOPE ALONG WITH
ITEMS AND PRODUCTS BUT ARE YOU
ALL. TO PUT THEMSELVES THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ON
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T
THROW IT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
GO TO ONE NINETY BUT. ONE
NINETEEN YES. HI MY NAME IS
JESSE VOEPEL I AM WITH OUR THIRD
UNITE REPRODUCTIVE AND GENDER
EQUITY- AND I STRONGLY URGE AND
I EIGHT FOUR EIGHT THANK YOU.
ANTIC COMMITTEE CHAIR NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES THE
PORTION OF THE MEETING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
ARE THERE ANY ED ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SIGNAL NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION. ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY TWO AT THIS TIME. CNN
WILL MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
PORTION. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IT.
SURE NO OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEY CAN
CAUSE A PORTION OF THE MEETING
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE SINGLE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME. AND
SEEING THAT WERE STILL. LACKING
QUORUM WITH ONE MEMBER. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
pCOMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME ASSEMBLY ONE COLOR AND YOU
WISH TO CLOSE YES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER NAY VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL TAKE UP THIS BILL
MAVERS ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE WE JUST HAVE
CONCLUDED FILE ITEM THIRTEEN. WE
NOW TAKE A LOOK TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO PRESENT AT
THIS TIME. I SEE AN ADDITIONAL
AUTHOR HERE IN THIS ROOM AT THIS
TIME IF YEARS READY THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN. IF HE IS
READY FILE ITEM NUMBER. FIFTEEN
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL YOU CAN FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN. IF YOU COULD SEE COUNTY
ALL HOLD FOR ONE MOMENT SO THAT
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MEDINA CHOI ARAMBULA BLOOM
GABRIEL- WHEN. KILEY LEVINE. LOW
HERE SANTIAGO BALLADARES WEBER.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM THEY
GIVE VERY MUCH. BACK TO SUMMER
GABRIEL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I FORGOTTEN THE INTIMACY OF THIS
ROOM SO IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY THREE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA TAKE
ANNUALLY TRAIN THEIR STUDENTS ON
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THE CRISIS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AT OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HAS BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED. RECENT STUDIES
SUGGEST UP TO ONE THIRD OF
UNDERGRADUATE WOMEN EXPERIENCE
NON CONSENSUAL SEXUAL CONTACT.
STUDIES ALSO PROVE THAT
SURVIVORS OF NON CONSENSUAL
SEXUAL CONTACT OFTEN EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL EMOTIONAL
ACADEMIC AND PROFESSIONAL
CONSEQUENCES. WELL EXISTING LAWS
REQUIRE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAMMING. INSTITUTIONS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO TRAIN
THEIR STUDENTS ON THESE TOPICS.
WELL SOME INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ADOPTED STRONG TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS INDEPENDENTLY OTHER
CAMPUSES AND INSTITUTIONS HAVE
NOT. IN ADDITION MANY TRAININGS
FOCUS ON THE PREVENTION OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE OR INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT TO DO AFTER AN
INCIDENT OCCURS IS NOT A
COVERED. LEAVING MANY SURVIVORS
TO FEEL LOST ABOUT WHERE TO GO
OR WHAT TO DO. AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE THESE
TRAININGS TO NOT ONLY COVER THE
TOPIC OF PREVENTION BUT ALSO
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES FOR WHAT TO DO AFTER
AN INCIDENT OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
OCCURS. BETTER ACCESS TO
RESOURCES AND EDUCATION WILL
EMPOWER SURVIVORS TO TAKE ACTION
INCREASE REPORTING OF INCIDENTS.
THROUGH THIS TRAINING AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY THREE ONE SURE THAT
THERE IS A BASELINE LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT STUDENTS HAVE
REGARDING SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
pPROTECT THE SAFETY AND SUCCESS
OF ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE SONYA
DHARMA DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING
FOR CHEN UP COLLEGIATE. AND
JASMINE PROSODIC VICE PRESIDENT
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENTS SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THANK YOU AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. I BELIEVE SELF. YOU ARE GOING
TO I'M- WITNESSES. OF. AS YOU
WATER. I GUESS SLIGHTLY HERE YOU
SURE UP. YEAH AT&T MODERATOR WE
COULD GO TO THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TRICKS
PRESS SUPPORT THIS BILL HE'S
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MORE. WE'LL GO TO LINE THE
FORTY FOUR IT'S GOING. HI BURKE
ACCURATE- COLLEGE STUDENT AND
EXPRESSING MY SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND TO HELP. SURE THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES ON IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOPIC THANK
YOU. WE GO TO LATE THANK ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BIGELOW WE'LL GO
TO LINE FIFTY NINE WITH BUT-
AFTERNOON THIS IS MAGGIE WHITE
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSOP ED CALLING
IN PART OF AB T. SIX EIGHT THREE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND
NEXT LINE- TO FIND FORTY FIVE
BUT. HELLO MY NAME IS NOT THE
IDEA OF THE UC STUDENT AND A
MEMBER OF GENERATION OUT BY
VOICE STRONG WORKSHOP BURKE
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU. ONE OF THE- MUCH OF.
THE LINE SIXTY GO AHEAD. A
MONTHLY. FIND SIXTY MAKE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NOW- YOU MAY SPEAK
LATICS. HI MY NAME IS KAREN AND
I'M LOOKING AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES I'M AND I
AM PART OF GENERATION A CALLING
AB TWO SIXTY THREE. THANK YOU.
MR CHER NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND THE MYSTERY WHERE
WE STILL HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
YOUR WITNESSES AND IN SUPPORT SO
I THINK YOU HAVE ONE HERE YES
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK READ THE
LINE FOR THE- YOUR SECOND. SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN YES THANK
YOU AND I PROMISES LAST TIME YOU
HEARING FROM YOU TODAY- I'D LIKE
TO START OFF BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL FOR
ADVOCATING ON IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT CONTINUE TO RISE WITHIN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THAT SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT AND ASSAULT IS A
SERIOUS MATTER. THAT CAUSES LONG
TERM EFFECTS TO STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. 35% OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT BY ANOTHER PERSON ON
CAMPUS. WITHIN THE FIRST WEEK OF
CLASS ONE OF MY CAMPUSES-
CLASSMATES WARNED ME ABOUT A
SPECIFIC SPORTS TEAM BECAUSE
THEY WERE KNOWN FOR SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT. STUDENTS NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT THE MEANING OF CONSENT AS
WELL STOPPING SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
AND OR HARASSMENT. 20% OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
TRANSFERRED TO UC AND THIRTY TWO
TRANSFERRED TO A CSU.
ESTABLISHING AN ANNUAL TRAINING
IN EACH SECTOR ALLOW STUDENTS TO
FEEL SAFE NO MATTER WHAT
INSTITUTION FOR CAMPUS THEY
ATTEND. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE ALWAYS STRAIGHT OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL. MANY COME BACK
YEARS LATER. BECAUSE OF THIS THE
STUDENT BODY OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS INTEGRATED
THROUGHOUT ALL LEVELS OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE MAKING
PROPER EDUCATION ABOUT SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT.
CRITICALLY ARE IMPORTANT.
STUDENTS ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP STRENGTHEN
TITLE NINE REGULATIONS TO ENSURE
CAMPUS SAFETY. MY MANY VICTIMS
ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK TO THE DRAMA
THEY FACE IN THEIR LIFE. I
POLITELY URGENT I THOUGH ON AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY THREE TO
PROTECT OUR STUDENTS AND EMPOWER
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT. IN DOING SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH STRONGER PROTECTION
SECURITY AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL WHAT WAS THE NAME AYE
I'M SO SORRY I THINK SO SIGN
YOUR DHARMA WHO IS OUR FIRST
PRIMARY WINNER SINCE APART I
BELIEVE IS ON THE LINE SONYA.
DHARMA YEAH SO MR EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IF WE COULD ****
SONYA. GARMENT TO SEE IF SHE'S
ON THE LINE- WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
OF YES YOUR THEIR. GOOD EVENING
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
FINE YOU'RE GONNA DO NOT GET
THEIR COLLEGE OF THE CLAREMONT
COLLEGES AT THE RED ONE OF THE
CREATIVE DIRECTORS OF ORGANIZING
FOR GENERATION UP TO YOU BUT
EDUCATIONAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND PROUD SPONSOR
AB TWO SIX EIGHT THREE OUR MAIN
GOAL AT JOHN UP REMAINS TO
ADVOCATE FOR STUDENTS ENSURING
THAT ALL OF US GROW LEARN AND
INTERACT IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WE FEEL SAFE AND SUPPORTED.
EVERYTHING WANNA WISH YOU ALL A
VERY REFLECTIVE SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH I'M GRATEFUL
THAT MY COLLEGE MANDATE AT THIS
STAGE PREVENTION TRAINING AS A
PART OF OUR CAMPUS ORIENTATION
HOWEVER IT IS SOMETIMES TOO LATE
BOB INCIDENCES FROM OCCURRING
ONE NIGHT I FOUND MY FRIEND
WALKING ON CAMPUS ALONE STOPPING
SHE EXPRESSED THAT SHE HAD NOT
SLEPT IN THREE DAYS THROUGH THE
DAY TO THE FOLKS AT. TWENTY SIX
POINT 4% OF FEMALES AND SIX
POINT 8% OF MALES EXPERIENCING
RAPE OR SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE YEARS SHE'S NOT
ALONE IT SEEMS EASY TO SIMPLY
LEAVE AN UNSAFE SITUATION
DEFENSEMAN OFTEN LEAD TO SELF
BLAME AND BUCK LOWER REPORTING
RATES AND ELONGATED SUFFERING
FOR SURVIVORS. BUT THEN EXISTING
TRAINING AND RESOURCES BUT THE
POINT MANY OF US ARE LOCKED THAT
IN TIMES OF HARDSHIP CONNECTING
WITH THE BROADER COMMUNITY IS
KEY FOR GREATER ACCESS TO
LOCALIZED RESOURCES REPORTING
OPTIONS AND SUPPORT SERVICES
WHEN UNDERGOING DRAMATIC AT THE
STATE INCIDENCES AB TWO SIXTY
THREE THIRDS OF AN AVENUE
TOWARDS. EMPOWERMENT FOR ME AND
MY FELLOW STUDENTS. MY FRIEND
INSTEAD OF BEING LEFT PERSONAL.
THERE AND CALLS NOT ORGANIZED.
SHOULD HAVE A PLAY TO GO. AND
HAVING BEEN TRAINED NO WORD FIND
CONTACT FOR CAMPUS AND THE
STOCK. CAN YOU RESOURCE. FOR
EXAMPLE AID THAT PROVIDES HER
OPTIONS AND SUPPORT THROUGHOUT.
S. B. H. INCIDENTS THAT ARE
THOUGHT WE PROBABLY WENT
INFILTRATING EVERY ASPECT OF.
THEIR LIVES. I'M EDUCATION TO
RELATIONSHIPS THE HELP. OF THE
COLLEGE AND COMMUNITY WE CAN AND
MUST DO BETTER. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING
STUDENTS AND FOR YOUR TIME AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB. TWO SIX EIGHT THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE LINE. EXPECT THAT MISSION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS PAST. MR I WANT TO NOT THIS
NOT THIS TIME THANK YOU ANY
TWEETERS IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE ANY TWEETERS MISTER
MODERATOR ON THE LINE. AND YOUR
POSITION IS TO ENTER THE EXPRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE. NO TO INTERRUPT
THE STATE DEFENSIVE. THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A SO
IT'S NOT REALLY A- COMMENT IS
THIS WORKING YEAH OKAY- SO
REALLY COMMENT ON THE BILL BUT I
JUST WANTED TO COMMEND THIS
PRASAD THE U. LIKE APOLOGIZE
ABOUT OR TOLD US IT IS COULD BE
THE LAST TIME I HAVE TO HEAR
FROM YOU TODAY YOUR FANTASTIC
LIKE YOU'RE DOING SUCH A GREAT
JOB- I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME.
I HAD TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
COMMITTEE WHEN I WAS A COLLEGE
STUDENT. AND I STILL REMEMBER
THE TRAUMA. AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
JUST LIKE YOU. LIKE PRESENT AND
CRIED TESTIMONY ON AS MANY BILLS
AS YOU CAN WHILE YOU'RE A
STUDENT AND YOU'RE- A PRO SO I
JUST WANT TO COMMEND YOU YOU'RE
DOING A FANTASTIC JOB THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M KINDA- TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE TESTIMONY AS
WELL I CAN. THANK YOU MR LEVINE
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN TO THE AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I- TO MR
LEVIN'S COMMENT MAYBE WE'LL SEE
VICE PRESIDENT ASSAD ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE- THE DICE ONE
DAY I SUSPECT WE MIGHT- I WOULD
JUST SAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
YOU KNOW IT I THINK CALIFORNIA'S
DONE GREAT WORK TO PROVIDE. TO
MANDATE TRAINING FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND A
LOT OF DIFFERENT. VENUES WE NOW
REQUIRED ANNUALLY IN THE
WORKPLACE- BUT WE KNOW FROM THE
STATISTICS THAT OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES OR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION ARE ONE OF THE
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE ARE MOST
VULNERABLE AND SO TO ME IT
SEEMS. MOST APPROPRIATE TO
DIRECT THE TRAINING AND THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THE RESOURCES TO
AREAS WHERE FOLKS ARE MOST AT
RISK- I THINK THAT THAT WOULD DO
THIS AND SO WITH THAT WHAT IT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. I THANK THE AGA. EXCUSE ME
OR THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD. AND THANK HIM
FOR. HIS WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- I WOULD
STRONGLY. BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. TODAY AND- LOOK FORWARD.
TO MY COLLEAGUES DOING THE SAME.
SO WE HAD A- MOTION BY MISTER
LOWE IS SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
AND MADAM SECRETARY VIEWED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I
CHOI. ARAMBULA BLOOM. BLOOM I
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I- WHEN- WHEN
I'D KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO
I SANTIAGO. VALDEZ WEBER WEBER
I'D. OKAY SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS MISTER. AND NOT
SEEN- MR HOLDEN. I BELIEVE I
HAVE THE- THE LAST COUPLE OF
BILLS BEFORE MR HOLDEN SO I WILL
CALL MR LOW BACK. FOR THE
GOBBLED AND I WILL PRESENT. TWO
ONE. RATHER. FOUR OKAY WHAT WHAT
LET'S LET'S DO WELL. OKAY I'LL
GO AHEAD PRESENT.
YEAH. THIRTY OF ANY PREFERENCE
ON. SPECIFIC BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO TO FILE ORDER YES THAT
WOULD BE FINE IF YOU REMIND ME
WHAT THE ORDER IS. T. DAY IF OUR
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN. I'M
SORRY. CORRECTION FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY. UP OKAY. FILE ITEM
S. OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR
VERY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M SORRY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING A. B.
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR BUT
STRENGTHENS THE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND INVESTIGATION
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT UNDER TITLE
NINE. IN RECENT YEARS UNITED
STATES OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
HAS OPENED FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE CASES PERTAINING TO
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
MISHANDLING OF REPORTS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND DISCRIMINATION- IN
THE RESEARCH BY THE CHRONICLE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. ONLY SEVENTY
FIVE OF THESE CASES HAVE BEEN
RESOLVED. AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR
CREATES A COMPREHENSIVE
OVERSIGHT PROCESS OF EMPLOYEES
AT PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL INSURERS A PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTION BE AWARE.
OF PENDING OR COMPLETED
INVESTIGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT
WHEN HIRING AN APPLICANT FOR A
POSITION. MORE OVER IT REQUIRES
INSTITUTIONS TO SHARE RECORDS OF
PREVIOUS EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE BEEN
FORMALLY INVESTIGATED. AND FOUND
VIA THE TITLE NINE PROCESS TO
HAVE COMMITTED SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT- OF GONE THROUGH THE
INFORMAL PROCESS. FINALLY AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR ESTABLISHED
POSITIONS ON CAMPUS IS TO ADVISE
AND SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE
EXPERIENCED SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND MISCONDUCT ON CAMPUS. I AM
PLEASED TO BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WHICH
ALLEVIATE ANY CONCERNS AND
OPPOSITION WITH THE BILL. HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IS TO MCCARTY A TITLE
NINE COORDINATOR FOR CSU. SHE'S
HERE TO LEND HER EXPERTISE ON
THE CURRENT TITLE NINE PROCESS
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR. WE HAVE
A NO TESTIMONY NO WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK AS A PRIMARY
WOULD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME BUT WE HAVE STILL ON
STANDBY FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS TO BE ANSWERED. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME ON ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR CNN WILL
OPEN P THE LINES. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ON
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE RIGHT. MR WE HAVE-
FIND IN FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ON
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR SEE NON OPERATIVE WOULD YOU
PLEASE OF THE DEADLINES FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ON ASSEMBLY
BILL. EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR. I
WISH TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
PRESS ONE THEN FOR AT THIS TIME. GIVE A RESPONSE FIND IN BUT.
YOU KNOW PATRICIA RUCKER THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE NOT SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
WE WANT TO THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE
MR MEDINA DOCTORS WORKING WITH
OUR STAFF AND OUT TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD ABOUT THE
BILL'S. GOING TO PROVIDE
CLARIFICATION ABOUT THE
INTENTIONS FOR THE NEW POSITION
CREATED AND WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE INTENTION TO NAIL THE BILL
TO ADDRESS THE LANGUAGE AROUND
THE INVESTIGATION OF HARASSMENT. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
DOING THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR WE HAVE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION IT'S NOT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES THE
PORTION OF THE MEETING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SINGLE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME SURE MEDINA DO WISH TO
CLOSE. JUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THERE'S BEEN A IS
THERE A MOTION. WELCOME BY MR
BLOOM CITED BY MR LEVINE FROM A
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI. ARAMBULA BLOOM
. BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I-
WHEN- IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW HI LOW HI SANTIAGO
BALLADARES WEBER. WEBER II. THE
BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES THE BILLS
OUT BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. AS CHAIR
WILL NOW MOVE ON. THE ACCEPTABLE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I PRESENT A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
SIX. A BILL WHICH WILL INCREASE
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS THAT A PART
TIME COACH CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY MEMBER MAY TEACH
AT ANYONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
SIX WOULD CHANGE THE PERCENTAGE
OF HOURS A PART TIME TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEE MAY TEACH UP 285% OF
THE HOURS PER WEEK THAT A FULL
TIME EMPLOYEE HAS. AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SIX WILL ALSO CHANGE THE
PERCENTAGE OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT LOAD. TO THE RANGE OF
8285% FOR ANY NEW AGREEMENT OR
UPON EXPIRATION OF ANY
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT IN EFFECT
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF MICHAEL YOUNG ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH THE CHAIR. THIS
YOUNG IN THIS GOVERNMENT PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER READY. THANK
YOU AT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
OBVIOUSLY- IN STRONG SUPPORT- AS
MR- MEDINA IT PREVIOUSLY SAID
THE BILL IS SIMPLY RAISING THE
CAP ON. THE NUMBER OF HOURS A
PART TIME FACULTY CAN WORK- IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM-
THERE TOO MANY PART TME FACULTY
WHO HAVE TO DRIVE FROM DISTRICT
TO DISTRICT THE DISTRICT TO
PIECE TOGETHER A FULL TIME
LITTLE RIGHTIES FREEWAY FLYERS.
WHO SPEND MORE TIME ON THE
FREEWAY THAN THEY CAN A
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS BY RAISING THE CAP OUR
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PART TIME FACULTY CAN SPEND MORE
TIME IN THE CLASSROOM AND MORE
TIME PROVIDING THOSE CENTRAL
SERVICES. THAN DRIVING FROM ONE
DISTRICT TO THE NEXT THIS IS A
CRITICAL FOR ENSURING THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING AS INADEQUATE SORT OF
PART TIME FACULTY WORKS WORKS
WHERE ARE YOU A FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS- AND ALSO IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY SO- WITH THAT I WOULD
ALSO ADD THAT PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS BILL. AT THE
HEAD NO OPPOSITION BUT- WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET FOR ISSUES
AROUND ANY HEALTHCARE COSTS THAT
COULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL SO YOU COMBINE THAT WITH
SORT OF THE COMMONSENSE REFORM
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO. AND.
WE START WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
UNDER THE CURRENT 67% THRESHOLD
MANY PART TIME FACULTY MUST AS
MICHAEL JUST MENTIONED. TEACHING
MULTIPLE DISTRICTS TO TRY TO PUT
TOGETHER A FULL OR EVEN GREATER
THAN FULL TIME SCHEDULE. THIS
LIMITS THEIR ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY IT LIMITS THEIR
ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN SHARED
GOVERNMENTS WERE CONNECTED
SENATE. AND BE A RESOURCE TO
STUDENTS. AND RURAL DISTRICTS
WHERE IT'S DIFFICULT TO HIRE
ENOUGH FACULTY THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY ALLOW COLLEGES TO OFFER
MORE CLASS ACTIONS TO A SINGLE
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBER. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
CAN TO ADDRESS SOME
MISCONCEPTIONS. BY COMPARISON
THE UC AND CSU SYSTEMS DO NOT
HAVE A CAP IN PART TIME FACULTY
HOURS. THIS BILL WOULD THEN
ALLOW THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
MORE CLOSELY ALIGN. TO OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
THIS BILL ALSO DOES NOT AFFECT
THE GRANTING OF TENURE TEN YEARS
A PRINCIPLE OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM
AND ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY
PROFESSORS. IT SHOULD BE
AFFORDED TO ALL PROFESSORS
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THEY TEACH. IT ALSO
DOESN'T CHANGE THE NUMBER OF
CLASSES TAUGHT BY FULL TIME
FACULTY AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE 7525% LINE ACTED
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF SECTIONS-TAUGHT BY FULL TIME FACULTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. AND HAS
CREATED AN ARTIFICIAL CEILING
WITH THE MANDATE OF A DISTRICTS
FULL TIME OBLIGATION NUMBER OR
FUND. THE FUND IS MEANT TO BE A
FLOOR. OF ORDER MINIMUM NUMBER
FACT FULL TIME FACULTY TEACH
DISTRICTS. ALTHOUGH EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN A FIFTY SIX DOES
NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
FOR MORE FULL TIME FACULTY. IT
DOES PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PART TIME FACULTY TO HAVE A
GREATER IMPACT ON THE LIFE OF
OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR SUCCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS COLEMAN
. OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE A NINE FORTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOT THE IDEA- YOU DIDN'T AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF GENERATION UP
ON THEN PEOPLE FOR THE BILL.
LINE. FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU THE
MEMBERS- JORDACHE REMEMBER
GENERATION UP AND EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF- OUR
MEMBERS WERE PICKED APART THE
ECOLOGIST THANK YOU. WIND. SIXTY
SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
WELL- I MEAN YOU SEE THAT CHINA
AND WE ON SHAMPOO AND EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BLIND SIXTY FIVE. DAVID HAWKINS-
WITH CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INDEPENDENT THAT WE'RE
ALSO COSPONSORED BABY EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SIX AND- YOU'RE RIGHT.
LINE. FIFTY SIX. YES THIS IS
JOHN MARTIN CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE
CAN PLEASE. NEARLY YES WE CAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
JOHN ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION RESTORED URGE
EVERYONE WHO'S COMMITTED TO
SUPPORT THE DEALERS BILL THE
RACE TO CAP THE 85% WHICH- SHE
DID IT IS NOT A PERFECT SYSTEM
BUT. WE'LL GO FOR IT THANK YOU
MR MEDINA. THANK YOU MR NO OTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE COMMITTEE ROOM
RECENTLY SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME ON ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX. YES PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE-
MIKE AND JUST SIMPLY YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT. GENEVIEVE COUNTY SHOW
FOR YOU SEE STUDENT AND MEMBER
OF CHEN UP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ATTENDING IN PUBLIC. ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. CNN WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION OTHER
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM AT
THIS TIME. SEAMAN WILL MOVE ON
TO THE- LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OF THE LINES FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR
COLLEAGUES THIS DOESN'T DO I DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE WILL TURN IT
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE MAN. CARE MEDINA JEWISH TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO
I HAVE A MOTION. WELL THAT IS
THE BLOOMS ALL BY MR LEVINE
COMMITTEE SECTION WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI ARAMBULA
BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL. GABRIEL
I IRWIN IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW HI LOW I'D SANTIAGO
BALLADARES WEBER WEBER I'D-
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS CHAIR MEDINA
WILL GO ON TO THE A FINAL BILL
PRESENTATION WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE. FORTY ONE.
COLLEAGUE THIS DOES ENJOY A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES DAHLE J. MEDINA PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHATEVER
READY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE. THE
FEDERAL AID ACCESS FOR ALL ACT
WHICH CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
TO ACCESS. THEIR FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID. SPECIFICALLY AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE
AUTHORIZES THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
TO ENTER A CONTRACT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF STATE AUTHORIZATION
. WITH A PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION ESTABLISHED BY
ANOTHER STATE THIS BILL WILL NOT
CHANGE THE QUALIFICATIONS FOR
STATE FINANCIAL AID OR CAL GRANT
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS
MEGAN SUBER'S ON BEHALF OF
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MAKE
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF ARIZONA
STATE UNIVERSITY I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THAT CHAIR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- WE LOVE WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND ALSO WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
WE WORKED ON THIS ISSUE WITH
PREVIOUSLY- I'M A ISSUE IS A
PUBLIC RESEARCH UNIVERSITY
ESTABLISHED IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE AND IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES N THE
COUNTRY. HOUSE IN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN A S. YOU- THROUGH
THEIR CAMPUSES N ARIZONA AND
ABOUT FIFTY TWO THOUSAND ALUMNI
IT ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
INCLUDING MYSELF- SO I'M I HAVE
A PERSONAL INTEREST AND
EXCITEMENT ABOUT THIS BILL AND
THEY'RE EXCITED IF HE WAS
EXCITED ABOUT THEIR PLANS TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO
STUDENTS AT THEIR NEW LOCATION
IN DOWNTOWN THE LOS ANGELES AT
THE CALIFORNIA CENTER. THEY'VE
REVAMPS THE OLD HERALD EXAMINER
BUILDING IN DOWNTOWN LA WITH THE
INTENT OF PROVIDING
UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATE AND
RESEARCH PROGRAMS TO- STUDENTS-
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AT THAT
LOCATION IN LA- SO THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO ALLOW A PROCESS FOR
A PUBLIC INSTITUTION TO MEET
FEDERAL REGULATION- AND HAVE
THIS COMPLAINT PROCESS PROCESS
SET UP SIMILAR TO THE WAY THAT
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTIONS- CAN
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT WITH THE
BUREAU. OF SO CALIFORNIA HAS A
CLEAR PATH FOR ALMOST EVERY
OTHER IN THE INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION INCLUDING
PRIVATE ITS INDEPENDENCE BUT
BECAUSE AS YOU IS A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY FROM ANOTHER STATE-
THIS THIS BILL IS NEEDED SO WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO- MOVING
THIS BILL THROUGH AND APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I SEE NO
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WITNESSES
LISTED BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE AT
THIS TIME C. NINE WILL BELONG TO
THE OPERATOR OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE. YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THANK YOU KNOW LONDON
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
pCOMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE C. NINE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIM. IF YOU
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEE NON. MISTER CHAIR DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEDITATE IN A MOTION
AND A SECOND PLEASE. MOVED BY A
DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY MISTER
BLOOM COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE- BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI
MEDINA I CHOI ARAMBULA BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
IRWIN- IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW HIGH LOW HIGH
SANTIAGO BALLADARES WEBER. WEBER
II THE- BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
AND. MOVING TO THE LAST ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A.
B. TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN MR
HOLDEN WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
PART. THIS IS YOUR THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS OF A BEATS TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN CONTINUES TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESS OF THE COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS OR C. CAP
FACT ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WHICH FORMALIZES
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. IT WAS NOT
LONG AGO THAT THE ONLY STUDENTS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS HAD THE
HIGHEST GPAS AND SOUGHT OUT
THESE PROGRAMS AS ADDITIONAL
CURRICULAR OPPORTUNITIES DURING
THEIR SENIOR YEAR BEFORE HEADING
OFF TO COLLEGE. HOWEVER DOING
ROMAN IS NOW SEEN BY EDUCATORS
RESEARCHERS AND POLICY MAKERS AS
A CRITICAL PATHWAY TO HELP BROAD
RANGE OF STUDENTS SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION FROM HIGH SCHOOL. TO
POSTSECONDARY CAREERS. TAKING A
MOMENT TO REFLECT I BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE PROUD OF
HOW FAR WE'VE PROGRESSED ON DUAL
ENROLLMENT IN THE FACT PAST FEW
YEARS WE EVEN HAVE A COMMITMENT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. UNDERSCORING HOW
CRITICAL THESE PROGRAMS ARE MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD LIKE TO
EITHER BEGIN OR EXPAND THEIR
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS BUT
LACKS THE ABILITY TO DO SO.
THESE CHALLENGES RANGE FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE LIMITATIONS TO
EFFECTIVELY INTEGRATING DUAL
ENROLLMENT AND A COLLEGE WIDE
STRATEGY. AB TWENTY SIX SIX
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN SIX TO
ADDRESS THOSE LIMITATIONS BY
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR NEW C. CAP
PROGRAMS AND EFFECTIVE TEMPLATE
THE COLLEGES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN USE TO ESTABLISH
THEIR PARTNERSHIPS. THIS BILL
ALSO PROVIDES FUNDING FOR DUAL
ENROLLMENT PARTNERSHIPS BASED ON
HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES WHICH WILL
INCREASE STUDENT ACCESS AND
PROGRAM VISIBILITY. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
COUPLE THESE DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITH ROBUST
STUDENT EVER ADVISING BECAUSE IT
IS CRITICAL STUDENTS HAVE THE
UPROAR CREATE SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE THROUGHOUT THEIR
COLLEGE CAREER. ANOTHER
CHALLENGE WITH DUAL ENROLLMENT
IS THE LOW REPRESENTATION OF
NATIVE AMERICANS LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS IN
THESE PROGRAMS. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE CONCRETE STEPS TO
REACH OUT TO THE STUDENTS SO AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDES RESOURCES
TO EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE DAHLE
ROMAN OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED. IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE HAVE MET THE
CHALLENGE BY ESTABLISHING DUAL
ENROLLMENT AS AN EFFECTIVE
PATHWAY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
NOMINEE MUST MEET THE NEW
CHALLENGE OF BUILDING INTENTION
AND TO DEAL IN ROMAN PROGRAMS
AND POLICY. HERE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL OUR MANY RODRIGUEZ WITH ED
TRUST WEST AND LENA HE BOUGHT. A
GRADUATING SENIOR FROM KERMAN
HIGH SCHOOL AND A STUDENT AT
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
STE. THEY BEGIN. HELLO EMILY A
WHAT I'M A GRADUATING SENIOR
FROM CARMEN HIGH SCHOOL I AM
ALSO A STUDENT AT FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE I WILL BE GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL BY THE END OF THE
SEMESTER I WILL HAVE ASSOCIATES
DEGREE IN MEDICAL ASSISTING AND
ALLIED HEALTH BY THIS FALL BUT
MY PLAN IS TO GO MUCH FURTHER MY
EDUCATION MY PLAN IS TO GET MY
BACHELOR'S IN NURSING AS
SACRAMENTO STATE AND EVENTUALLY
COMPLETE THE GRADUATE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT AT UC DAVIS. FOR MY
PARENTS AND I THIS WILL BE A
pBOTH MY PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
DID NOT GO PASS ON MENTERI%
SCHOOL THROUGHOUT MY HIGH SCHOOL
YEARS I WANTED TO GIVE A CHANCE
TO SOMETHING YOU HAVE ALWAYS
WANTED TO SEE IF I COULD DO MORE
THAN JUST HIGH SCHOOL BY THE
TIME I GRADUATED BY THE TIME I
WAS A SOPHOMORE I WONDERED IF
THERE WAS A WAY TO START COLLEGE
WHILE IN HIGH SCHOOL. THAT IS
WHEN I WENT TO MY HIGH SCHOOL
CANCER MISTER NOT WHAT IT DID TO
ASK ABOUT IT HE TOLD ME THERE
WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
AND IT WAS CALLED ONE MOMENT I
TOLD HIM I WOULD LOVE TO ROLE
BUT TIME I SENT MY APPLICATION
AND I STARTED MY FIRST SEMESTER
OF THESE COURSES I STARTED TO
GET NERVOUS BECAUSE I THOUGHT I
WAS NOT GOING TO BE SMART ENOUGH
TO HANDLE COLLEGE AND HIGH
SCHOOL. THANKFULLY I HAD THE
SUPPORT FROM BOTH MY HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE CANCERS AS WELL AS
MY TEACHERS TO HOW WE PURSUE MY
COLLEGE AND HIGH. SCHOOL CANCER
HELP ME ADVICE. TODAY GENERAL ED
. COURSES AS WELL AS CREATING AN
EDUCATIONAL PLAN. WITHOUT THE
SAPPORO HAVE NOT MADE IT. BEEN
ABLE TO DO IT THE BENEFITS FROM
THE ONE WOMAN ARE AMAZING. IT
HAS HELPED ME BOOST MY
CONFIDENCE BE MORE RESPONSIBLE
AND HELP ME IN HIGH SCHOOL I
ALSO LOVE IT LOVES IT BECAUSE IT
SHOULD HAVE A LIKE A- LIKE AN
ADULT WHILE I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL. THIS ALSO HELP ME
CLARIFY MY CAREER GOALS DURING
MY FIRST SEMESTER NOT ONLY THAT
IT HELP ME GET YOU SMALL COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE TO SAVE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS AND SIGN. NOW I AM A
SENIOR WITH A TOTAL FORTY FIVE
COLLEGE UNITS. MOST ARE FROM
WEST HILLS COLLEGE OF CLINGER
AND SOME FROM FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE. DAHLE ROMAN HAS HELPED
ME BECOME THE WOMAN I AM TODAY
AND I HIGHLY ENCOURAGE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS TO TAKE.
DORMAN COURSES IT AND GIVE IT A
CHANCE BECAUSE IT WILL SHOW OUR
PARENTS WE HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TODAY THAN THEY
DID. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE ON AS MANY RODRIGUEZ
THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR POLICY
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST WE ARE A
RESEARCH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WORKING TO CLOSE OPPORTUNITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD. EDUCATION
THROUGH COLLEGE. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THINK OF SOME HOLDEN FOR
BEING A CHAMPION IN THE
TOURNAMENT SPACE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
EXPAND THIS PARTNERSHIP- THAT WE
JUST HEARD ABOUT THE AMAZING
BENEFITS. ADDRESS WES IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
BECAUSE WILL BOLT BOLSTERED ONE
WOMAN OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BY INCENTIVIZING MORE
L. E. ASE YOU TAKE UP THIS
PARTNERSHIP. COUPLE THAT ACCESS
WITH ADVISING TUTORING AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS. AND ENSURE
THAT THOSE OUTCOMES ARE STUDY TO
INFORM FUTURE INVESTMENT. IN OUR
MOST RECENT REPORT ETW JUMPSTART
WE OUTLINED THE STUDENT ACCESS
AN OUTCOME GAINS THAT WE'VE SEEN
THROUGH DUAL ENROLLMENT WHILE
ALSO CALLING OUT THE EQUITY GAPS
THAT HAVE YET TO BE. GAINED BY
BLACK NATIVE AMERICAN LATIN
EXPERIENCE. INEQUITABLE
PARTICIPATION AND WILL ROMAN IS
NOT JUST A CHALLENGE FOR ME
BECAUSE SYSTEM IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR LOCAL K.
TWELVE EDUCATION LEADERS TO
PROVIDE THEIR STUDENTS WITH MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL PREPARED FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. THE RESEARCH BY P. V.
I. C. CAREER LADDERS PROJECT ETW
AND OTHERS CLEARLY SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS NOT ON THE PATHWAY. TO
COLLEGE ARE THE ONES YOU SEE THE
BIGGEST GAINS FROM DOING ROAMING
. AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN AND
THE ACCOMPANYING FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET INVESTMENT
HAS BEEN PROPOSED WILL SERVE AS
A CATALYST TO DO JUST THAT. TO
REIMAGINE REBUILD TOURNAMENT AND
CLOSE RACIAL EQUITY GAPS. THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM. A SCENE
NINE IF WE COULD GO- MISTER
MODERATOR TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR HIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. BORDERLINE. FIFTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LED THE SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A COMMON FROM LINE
FIFTY SEVEN. FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS ELMER
MARTINEZ TOMATOES HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNCIL FOR A STRONG
AMERICA AND READY NATION TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THEY'RE
NOT FOR THE LINES IN Q. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THE SCENE NINE ANY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION ON THE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR. YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME. ANY TWEETERS
IN THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR. ADDITION OF
TWEENER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE SCENE NONE OF THE
AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU RESEARCHER I JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT SEEN A WONDERFUL
PERSON AND STUDENT LIKELY KNOWS
WHAT THIS PROGRAM IS ALL ABOUT
IT WHO IS DESIGNED TO HELPING
CREATE A VISION FOR FUTURE AND
CREATE OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF. TIME THAT
SHE WAS SPENDING COLLEGE WHICH
I'M SURE WILL MAKE HER PARENTS
WERE HAPPY. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
AND AS MR LEVINE- RECOGNIZE THE-
WITNESS FROM THE COLLEGE I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE YOU FOR BEING A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT. AND BEING
HERE IN FRONT GIVING. EXPERT
TESTIMONY AND- BEING A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER MYSELF HAVING
TAUGHT CONCURRENT CLASS REGULAR
TO TEACH- HISTORY MEXICO TO MY
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE
CREDIT I KNOW THE VALUE. OF WHAT
YOU'VE DONE AND WHAT MR HOLDEN
IS DOING HERE- WITH THIS BILL.
SO I WANT TO COMMEND MR HOLDEN
AND FOR HIS MANY YEARS OF BEING
AN ADVOCATE FOR THE- CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT AND ESPECIALLY FOR
MAKING IT UP FOR STUDENTS WHO
SOMETIMES HAD MEN TRADITIONALLY
ENROLLED. IN THAT I WANT TO
COMMEND HIM ADULT AND- SURE THAT
I WILL BE STRONGLY SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND- URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME. SO
DID I HAVE A MOTION. WE HAD OF
MOTION BY MISTER LOW A SECOND BY
MR GABRIEL AND. MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED TO
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI BALLADARES
WEBER WEBER I'D. NINE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLES. AND NOW WE WILL GO
TO- THE CONSENT CALENDAR HE'S. A
MOTION BY MISTER LOWE SECOND BY
DOCTOR RUMBULA ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA I
MEDINA HI CHOI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN. IRWIN I
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I BALLADARES.
WEBER WEBER I. NINE NINE ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND OHIO WE WILL GO
THROUGH THE- FILED FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS OKAY FILE ITEM ONE AB
SIXTEEN OH SIX THE MOTION S DUE
PASSED THE MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS I NEED A- MOTION AND A
SECOND. MOVED BY DR RUMBLE AND
SECOND BY MR GABER. MEDINA I
MEDINA HI CHOI ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
HIGH BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN- IRWIN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I VALLADARES WEBER.
WEBER I'D. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB. SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOVED BY MR LEVINE SECOND BY
MISTER BLUE. MEDINA HI MEDINA I
CHOI ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN-
WHEN I KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO
LO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I BALLOT
DOES WEBER. WEBER HI. NINE NINE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
THREE AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND. BY MR
LEVINE SECOND BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA. MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN-
WHEN I KILEY. LEVINE LEVINE I LO
LO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
VALLADARES WEBER WEBER AVE. NINE
NINE ZERO BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
FIVE A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR.
THE MOTION NO IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MOVED THE SECOND SERVICE OR
ADELINES CHILE. ARAMBULA RUMBULA
I KILEY SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
BALLADARES. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX
IT'S ALREADY BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. CHOI
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I- WENT- KILEY
. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I BALLADARES. NINE NINE ZERO BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
NINETEEN FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MADE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. BLOOMBERG MISTER LEVINE
SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBLE. MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI BELA ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I SANTIAGO
. SANTIAGO I VALIDUS WEBER WEBER
HI. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND IN MOTION AND THE
SECOND. OR BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA
SECOND BY MISTER BLUE. MEDINA HI
pAYE BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN- WHEN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW EYES
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE GALLAGHER
WEBER. WEBER II NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NINE. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE I NEE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MOVED BY MR BLOOM SECOND
BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA MEDINA HI
MEDINA HI CHOI. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA IRA BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I IRWIN- IRWIN
I KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I BALLADARES
WEBER. WEBER HI NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM TEN
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND. MOVED BY
DR WEBER SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBLE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA ARI BLOOM
BLOOM I GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
IRWIN. IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LO. LO I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE GALLAGHER WEBER
WEBER HI. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE IT HAS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE CHOI. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I KILEY SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI BALLADARES. NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB. TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY TWO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND
BY MISTER BLUE. MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE CHOI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I IRWIN- IRWIN%
I KILEY LEVINE. LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I BALLADARES
. VOTERS NOT VOTING WEBER WEBER
HI. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN IT HAS BEEN
MOVED IN SECOND. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO EUROPE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE CHOI. KILEY
VALLADARES BALLADARES I. TEN
ZERO TEN ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY THREE IT HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CHOI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I KILEY SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I BALLADARES BALLADARES
HI. ZERO TEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
CONSENT CALENDAR. CHOI KILEY
BALLADARES VALLADARES HI THERE
TEN ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
WELCOME TO OPEN. FOR SO WE'RE
GONNA GO THROUGH AGAIN YEAH.
YEAH NUMBER ONE. NUMBER ONE A
HOLD ON THE SECOND FLOOR OKAY OF
. SANTIAGO AND WHAT IT DOES
MESSED UP. ONE FIFTY RIGHT.
RIGHT AND SO I THINK THAT-
GALLAGHER OKAY ISSUE YOUR YOUR
YOU'RE ON EVERYTHING OKAY YEAH.
FOR OKAY LET'S SEE HOW QUICK
THAT NINE POINT. BUT I WANT.
EIGHT
THANK YOU SO. YEAH. NUMBER SIX
YOU'RE WELCOME SORRY THIS CRAZY
DAY NO NO NO NO IT WAS. YEAH
THOUGH I KNOW IT IS. A TO IT
ONCE MYSELF. YEAH ON. FIFTY SB.
DO YOU COMING FROM YEAH. YEAH IN
SALAS. WELL- AND- WHERE IS OUR
HERE WE GO. THANK YOU TO AND
CHOI. OKAY. OKAY GOOGLE ED. OKAY
FILE I ONE A. B. C. KNOWS. CHOI
CHOI I SALAD VALID ARMY. LEVIN'S
LOSE OUT FILE ITEM TO SO FIFTY
SO. CHOI I KILEY BALLADARES
VALDERS NOT VOTING. TEN ZERO
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM THREE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR. CHARLIE
CHOI I KILEY VALLADARES
VALLADARES HI. ELEVEN ZERO BILL
IS UP. FILE ITEM FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR CHOI CHOI I
KILEY VALLADARES BALLADARES HI.
ELEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM SIX AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX CHOI CHOI I
KILEY BALLADARES BALLADARES HI.
ELEVEN ZERO BILL IS UP. FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB NINETEEN FORTY TWO
CHOI CHOI I KILEY BALLADARES
BALLADARES HI. ELEVEN ZERO BILL
IS OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE CHOI. NOW
FORTY CHOI NOT VOTING. KILEY
VALLADARES. WELL THERE IS NOT
VOTING. NINE ZERO BILLS UP. FILE
ITEM NINE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN CHOI CHOI I KILEY
VALLADARES BALLADARES HI. ELEVEN
ZERO BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM TEN
AB. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. CHOI
CHOI I KILEY BALLADARES. WELL
THERE IS NOT VOTING. TEN ZERO
BILL IS UP. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE. CHOI
CHOI I KILEY VALLADARES.
BALLADARES HI. ELEVEN ZERO BILL
IS OUT. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO CHOI.
CHOICE NOT VOTING KILEY. NINE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. AB TWENTY SIX
SUPPORT TEAM FILE ITEM FOR ME
USING A FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN. CHOI CHOI
I KILEY. IN. ELEVEN ZERO BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY THREE CHOI CHOI I
KILEY. ELEVEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CHOI CHOI I
KILEY. ELEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT. I WANT TO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE STAFF THE RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER AND ALL WHO ENSURED
THAT THIS HEARING COULD TAKE
PLACE. THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A JERK.
JUST JUST WAY WAY. THANKS VERY
LONG. NINETEEN OKAY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY SIX- THE NEEDS TIME TO
HEAR A LITTLE SIXTY BILLS.
THAT'S GOING. YOU THIRTY. ARE
THERE ENOUGH.